here we go we're rolling what's up good
to see you guys it's always weird to
meet somebody when you watch a lot of
the YouTube content TV cotton and then
you're like you're real let's yeah we
all feel about each other I love you
guys thank you well same we feel the
same for sure you guys are honest I mean
we were talking about that earlier like
it's so rare that someone is just
calling it like it is like what you see
and obviously you guys don't agree on
everything and I you know no one does
but right we all have varying opinions
but you say what you feel and that is so
valuable today it's so unusual it's just
such a weird partisan time it is a weird
partisan time like it's never been
harder to actually just do that thing
and I can't say I mean we don't get it
right all the time but the whole idea
was to try to have this conversation
between kind of the new left and the new
right that wasn't happening at any
anywhere in a way that was valuing
people's humanity that was trying to
deal in the land of the honest not
cheerleading a team or the other but
actually trying to like be
straightforward about what we think and
evaluating the facts as we find them and
I mean I have to say like you have
somewhat created that space where that
can happen so I think we're in part
indebted to you you know absolutely and
you know it's crazy I think the reason
it works is because we both kind of came
up in quasi traditional background right
like Crystal came from the MSNBC world
like I was a White House correspondent
like I worked with a lot of these
traditional reporters and like you know
I would do Fox News and all these other
things and it just it's always so
frustrating when you're on TV you get
three and a half minutes to talk right
like I once did a segment on you know
nationalism which was to two and a half
minutes with three people on a put on a
panel like how are you supposed to get
your point across and so when you're
when you're doing that and you see like
so you can make an entire career in DC
just sticking to the party line no
matter what these people believe and you
just spit out the talkers and they
literally send you they'll send you
talking points they just say over is
that what is what is that like what is
that what is the talking but like you
get a sheet you would like a discuss
what it like wouldn't message of the day
here's the message of the day here
you're talking points top line then you
going you turn on fox news you can hear
it come out of there literally
word-for-word it turn on MSNBC you can
hear it word for word from the Biden
campaign to their surrogates it's all
planned man like it's all from service
nobody actually thinks for themself and
that when we came together like we were
hosting a show that's what set us apart
I mean I think that's why it's caught on
what's the incentive like is it the
incentive access money for you to stay
with the party line with it's a lot
safer I mean you know it's not easy to
sort of be out there on your own you
know and I don't want to paint just sort
of trying to be honest as a more noble
act than it actually is it's very safe
if you're within the party structure if
you're saying the things that they want
you to say there's a whole system set up
for that there's a career system set up
for that there's a system of protection
so you're allowed to be dramatically
wrong on things like the Iraq war or
things like the financial crisis if
you're wrong in the approved ways right
if you're wrong in the non approved ways
then you can get destroyed cancelled all
of those things so it's a lot safer to
stay within the bounds and and look like
we're living that in real time right now
I mean it's never been just with how
fraught you know you have pandemic where
people are dying you have Great
Depression so it's like the Spanish flu
and the Great Depression and then you
layer on top of that like all the chaos
of the 60s the lines have never been
more drawn at least in the time then
that we've been doing the show as they
are right now and so it's it is a it's
not an easy dynamic to navigate because
most of the country is just completely
coming apart yeah and I want to picking
up you're like why do you do it if you
do it you hop on establishment campaign
to establishment campaign campaign
cycles over you go work at a think tank
which is all your former buddies from
the campaign then you go and you do the
talking points you will always have a
job you will never suffer you'll never
even if nobody likes what you have to
say even if Republican voters or
Democratic voters have rejected your
message six out of seven popular vote
elections doesn't matter because the
money is there
and the people who have the money have
an interest in propping up that
infrastructure so when you get your
talking points you know that if you say
them you're in X is good graces and then
that person has to hire you they'll
throw you consulting contract they'll
throw you this they'll put your name
forward whenever it's time to staff up
in administration that's how the system
of the grift in the city actually works
and that's how they keep dissenting
voices in their own party down because
how do you how do you even get on TV or
how do you even become an authoritative
voice in your party you need credentials
right everything is credentialism well
how do you get those credentials they
control who enters the programs and they
control who they push they control who
they push forward and so that's how they
try to keep people who have dissenting
opinions out and it's like we said it's
because of the space that you opened up
where nobody knew that somebody wanted
to listen to a guy talk about chimps for
three hours that happened that created a
space where it's like no no there's a
lot of people who are fed up with this
[ __ ] but can I say also it's not just
that like direct career Grif trajectory
it's also that we're at this point in
the nation's history which again has
never been more obvious than right now
where the stakes feel really existential
and you know and that's that's a real
thing I mean before Trump's election
there was this flight 93's a where the
the argument was look if you're a social
conservative if you're not sure that
this Trump guy is for you this election
is existential you have to grab the
controls or else our way of life is
going to die now I don't agree with that
assessment I think that is hyperbolic I
think it's over-the-top you know the
conservative way of life is going to
continue in their churches and people
can do what they want to do but that's
the that was a legitimate sense among
the Trump base and of course we see it
with the the Democrats on the Left right
now and I would say at this moment it
has probably never been more true in
terms of that existential nature as we
see you know the president calling for
potentially military activation in
American cities and we see him using
tear gas and rubber bullets on peaceful
protesters so the fact that the stakes
feel so existential on both side
it's make it very very difficult to
engage in a way that is thoughtful
honest non hyperbolic and where
everyone's not just basically mad at you
all the time
how did you guys start your show well I
mean it's a crazy story so crystal was
co-hosting previously and this was
before kind of the show was on YouTube
and I think I fair to say was more like
standard yeah more of a standard
left-right kind of dynamic or we didn't
have this was just you know when I
started on the street took on the show
last year yeah yeah so before that for
about a year before that I'd been
co-hosting another guy great guy buck
Saxton and we had sort of a more
standard left-right dynamic sounds like
a porn star I used to fill in for buck
right when he was gone and Krystal and I
like we we found like we would click on
certain issues right like especially on
these are the things you see on the show
like on economics on the indictment of
the economic system about right even on
Charlie I'm not a Trump toady right like
I'm not if they give me the talking boys
like I'm if I say something if I think
something is good I'll say it's good and
everything it's something is bad then
that's bad and gets me into trouble it
gets Krystal into trouble too
don't define trouble I mean you know
people are pissed off at what you say
they'll tweeting like how dare you do
you read that stuff yeah that's the
price here is it I probably should I
would read more of it it's not that I
haven't liked smarter to not reaiiy
didn't like have kids that actually
helps a lot great satellite internet and
it sucks really hard it's actually great
so yeah that's recommend it yeah it
still helps if you're trying to upload
something it's virtually impossible so
yeah so when buck wanted to focus on his
radio show and you know one of the one
of the expectations of the hill which is
you know the corporate news brand that
sponsors us is that this would be a
left-right show
I thought let's do a left-right show in
a way that no one has done before where
normally the consensus the sort of
left-right consensus is like this we're
all moderates we're all corporate is we
believe in unity we believe in like low
taxes we believe in free trade deals
that's the in wars and those sorts of
things that's the sort of standard
bipartisan consensus that you're allowed
to have so we thought what if we did it
in a different left-right dynamic where
we actually have more overlap on some of
these economic issues and the dissent is
around more of the cultural issues and
and what does that look like because
that's actually more representative of
where the two parties are headed right
if you look at where young people are
it's also more representative of where
more Americans are I mean you know sagar
says and i think this is true there is
very little representation and has been
historically at least for people who are
like economically more left and
culturally more right all of the elite
conversation is this very like
economically liberal but on social
cultural issues economically more
conservative like balance the budget you
know taxes and stuff but on social
cultural issues more liberal as more the
elite conversation that is commonly
happening on cable news even though
that's reflective of like teeny tiny
portion of America that's 10 percent of
the population and they all live in like
New York City LA San Francisco it's like
the like what America is I would say
cult pretty culturally right not like
super ripe like center-right and
economically you could say cultural left
I mean a little bit left it depends on
how you define those things but one of
the I mean to eat those of the show
crystal actually said this I think to
the times was what if we hated each
other less and the elites more that's
kind of how we boil it down and I did
you guys have a concert in a
conversation before you started working
together yeah yeah sit down
how do you feel about this how do you
feel about that yeah I mean we because
he'd filled in before and you know I
mean you know when you have guests on
when you work with someone especially in
a media space you could you get a vibe
right away and you can tell right away
you know number one is this person like
ready to hold the chair ready to do this
thing do they have this sort of fully
formed coherent ideas or things they
want to explore that's gonna make sense
so just on that like surface level is
that gonna work but you also get a real
vibe for not even where are you
ideologically but are you willing to be
honest when your team is [ __ ] up and
look everyone looks at cable news even
if you are you know a kind of standard
down the line Democrat or a standard
Trump Republican no one believes that
these people are really shooting
straight with them everyone sees the
partisan cheerleading that is going on
in the normal cable news networks and so
it was very easy to see right away that
Sarah was a person who was willing to
you know to be honest where his own team
was concerned and to me that was kind of
the most important piece yeah I mean
insane right like which is that it's
when you're talking to somebody or on
cable or and just even in an argument
it's just standard talking about you and
you can catch them in one of those like
him what about isms it's just so
frustrating it's just and it's so
unproductive and that's this thing I
hated the most about you know my time
when I was in the White House press
corps it was very much just like the
quote you could predict every single
question before the briefing even began
every single one and it just used to
drive me nuts because you'd see these
people and they care a lot more about
getting cable news contracts and all
that than they ever do like actually
asking legitimate quiet or like real
questions about what you think of this
program or what it's all you know I mean
just to standard issue crap and like it
was like every single day and with
cristal was like fine like somebody's
willing to call out the problems on
their side and I was willing to do the
same thing I've kind of I've always been
like that and that's that's where we
were like we have something here and you
know I mean and then it just started to
take off we were I mean it was like we
just put it out into the ether and all
of a sudden it just started like
catching just you know you
the first thing that really caught was
we did an interview with the intro yeah
yep and I've actually known I'm not
Andrew for a long time great guy
just you know say like try to be honest
like really figure things out and he his
answer may not always be my answer but I
feel like he's really trying to figure
it out and come to a good place and see
the best in people
yeah and so we did this long-form
interview with him where I mean there
was nothing crazy about it we just
actually asked him policy focused
substantive questions for I don't know
30 minutes yes I think I was like 30 man
and it blew up and people loved it and
we're like before that we were getting
like hundred views like oh my god we got
a thousand views on that one right and
then and we post this Andrew yang video
and it's just like blows up and we
thought wow this is really really
interesting because of the questions we
asked it was like you were asking him
about not just ubi which is what he's
known for about like medicare-for-all
and all and I was asking on occasion I
asked him about the China trade deal and
about you know intellectual property and
tariffs and people loved that we just
asked them yeah willing to ask yeah yeah
and then it wasn't and that they weren't
stupid I mean that's the thing too at
that point is campaign forum everybody
basically except you it was getting
these really stupid questions about like
oh is it just white nationalists who are
supporting you and you know I really
picked up gang as like a mean thing like
it over like I don't even really
remember what the context was but I mean
he obviously disavowed it but people
were picking it up but why are all these
white national support it's like they're
obviously trolling dude like that's
crazy though that you can get in trouble
for the people that like you like you
get your figure you have no control over
that like how could he know that there's
white national said even have them on
the radar but it's and it's not even
that like you see this with any
candidate who comes from outside the
sort of established channels I mean you
see the same thing with with Tulsi you
saw the same thing with Bernie you saw
the same thing in some ways with Trump
is like they use who is supporting you
they find like the worst person that
and then they use that to dismiss the
whole thing like that way they don't
have to engage with your arguments or
your policy ideas or who you are what
you're doing as a person it's like this
person associated with with you is bad
ergo you are bad ergo we don't have to
deal with that at all I think some of
that has to do with this this quality of
posting things on social media like this
140 character now 280 character quality
of Twitter where you're just kind of
condensing things and it's this
reductionist view of stuff and then just
put it out there
oh he's racist oh he's sexist
oh he's supported by white nationalists
so and then BOOM
that's the narrative stick with it
there's no nuance run and think about
that right the cause they just like the
sheer amount of arrogance it takes to
just sum up somebody in like to 80
characters and respect this person is a
racist I think I don't even acknowledge
thee I mean do they know what it means
to call somebody that right I don't
think it's a real statement it's just
like you're saying it right but it's one
person talking to the ether right
there's no one's saying like says who
Sookie see and your gang is not a
[ __ ] white nationalist like what are
you talking about man like you need
someone in front of you going what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
like hehe oh he knows those guys are
supporting him and so he's going out of
his way to court them you're saying
right right stupid but no one's gets to
say that to them so they get to put
those tweeting is one of the worst ways
to gather information right it's one of
the worst ways to have a dialog because
especially when you're defining
something or someone and I feel the same
way about sometimes occasionally about
really self-righteous blogs and they
write an evil blog about someone that
person doesn't get a chance to respond
right now you're just sort of saying it
out there your perception of that person
and you can make all these horrible
distortions whether it's about Andrew
yang or Tulsi Gabbard or whoever yeah
you can make these horrible distortions
and then someone reads it and you're
you're putting out this distorted
unchallenged perception of someone
whereas if you were having a
conversation with you to them or someone
who you know was a more rational point
of view they could say well that's not
really true because she actually said
this right this is what she
and this is the greater context the
conversation we're constantly trying to
draw lines around like who are the good
people and who are the bad people and
like where's that bright line and which
side of the line are you on and you're
not allowed to associate with the people
on the the bad line yeah and I think
like social media obviously exacerbates
all of that makes a million times worse
no doubt about it because it's all so
simplistic it's also like sensationalist
driven it's all like keys into your sort
of like basic instincts and your
adrenaline and your dopamine response
and all of that but there's also been a
sort of strategy from you know the the
political and media elites in the
country where if you pit people against
each other and this is something Matt
Taibbi who's you know we had great guy
you had him on here he's fantastic
things about this great book hey hey
tank and his thesis is essentially that
once the Cold War ended and we didn't
have Russia to be the bad guy that the
new ratings innovation was to make each
other the bad guys and what does that do
first of all it's great for ratings cuz
you got an easy villain you know on Fox
it's people like me on MSNBC it's people
like soccer right it's easy villains
easy ratings you can find stories all
day long that support that narrative no
problem but it also saves any sort of
accountability from the people that are
in power because if you know people who
are out there in the country if the
voters are the problem if they are bad
if they are evil if they are deplorable
then it's not the fault of the people in
power that things are going wrong it's
not their fault that these terrible evil
sexist racist horrible people voted the
wrong way it's those people's fault and
so it saves them from ever having to do
any self-reflection or make any
adjustments in what they're doing and I
think it's a big part of why we are
where we are yeah I mean that's just
such a huge part of the show which is
just trying to draw a compassion for
people trying to understand what
motivates 65 I don't know the numbers I
think it's 60 something million to pull
the lever for Trump what happened there
right and that's just something that the
media has not spent any introspection
trying to understand what would compel a
person to do that what would compel a
person to vote
for Bernie Sanders it's I mean you know
they're like Oh Bernie Bros it's all why
I mean if you look at the data which we
talked about on our show
constantly it's just absolutely false
and it's it's in that way that you can
begin to understand and actually even
respond right and that's actually the
thing I love the most about the show is
sometimes I friends you know like on the
ride and they'll say something about the
leg the left thinks there's like no man
like I left coast and like that's not
what she says her response is XYZ I'm
sure the same thing happens with crystal
which is that you know why as you said
with Twitter condensing our rhetoric and
our politics to 280 characters and
trying to condense hyper complex and
multifaceted ideas and multifaceted
discussions and deep conversations down
to that level helps nobody and actually
all it does is help split people apart
for a pretty explicit reason which is
that part of the things that we talk
about on the show is the reason why you
know the elites the cultural elites
right and left kind of want everybody
split is because they don't want people
to have the uncomfortable conversation
around how the economy is structured
they don't every day that we talk we
have some you know cultural debate in
the country is every day that we're not
talking about how many million people in
this country are unemployed right now
about the political choice the political
choice and some of the thing I talk a
lot on the show about to allow people to
be forced off their payroll and to go
onto unemployment to allow businesses to
fail to allow people to suffer when we
have the explicit choice of allowing
them to keep their payroll I mean it's
something we've been focused on so much
because the implications of that when
you're also making the explicit choice
in order to you know cap the amount of
money that goes to a small business
program when you're doing you know big
checks in order to corporation or do to
the airlines which are firing people
anyway despite the fact that they got
like fifty billion dollars you don't
have a conversation about that that they
will never want to have that one because
they want people to hate each other more
yeah I think there's something about
using social media that also facilitates
mental illness and this is what I'm what
I mean like we all have varying degrees
of health right some days you run down
some days you feel great some days
you're coming down with a cold some days
you're in bed with the flu we all very I
think that there's something about the
kind of interactions that people are
having when they're arguing with [ __ ] on
Twitter that you could make a real I
think you could draw a graph on human
beings under their mental health yeah
and how much are you using social media
and how many interactions are you having
where you're arguing with people how do
you feel well it's funny Joe that that
actually happened to me like I spend all
day on Twitter I absolutely shouldn't
from getting into treatment I stop
myself on getting into most Twitter
fights please stay off of it the few
days after this podcast I took like a
vacation right before I can't I started
taking over the show I spent like ten
days off tweet and that's when the
Muller report came out and I made I was
like I'm not no Twitter and I just read
it in the paper where I actually went
found the link read the whole work it
was amazing I had all these like nuanced
thoughts like this I was like oh well
the mall report you know that shows this
oh this person was full of [ __ ] the
whole time but you don't need to go out
there and tweet it whereas if I had been
in my office at like this idiot
you know but it was it was great and I
should probably go back to that I've
incorporated some of it I broke my phone
once on vacation yeah I was in Hawaii
and you know if you want to order a
phone it took like I ordered it from
Apple it took like three days to get
there something like that yeah so for
four days no phone right and it was
amazing yeah it was amazing I was like I
feel so much more relaxed no I mean
these are like [ __ ]
they're likes Canarian like you know
reflex device Skinner like the you know
push the lever and get rewarded I mean
you see it with like I see with my kids
too if I let them have the device too
much they get all irritated and agitated
truly because it's the it is exact same
neural pathways those like dopamine
response systems as with any addiction I
mean it's you have engineers who are
making their living trying to figure out
how to program your brain to not ever
get off Twitter and not
get off whatever it is that you're
obsessed with on your phone or your
device and like that's what you're up
against Oh humble about I just have so
many friends that have that problem like
sometimes I'll text them then I'll get
back a green bubble and I'm like did you
switch to Android nah man I switch to a
flip phone right wean myself I mean we
we don't have good broadband access
where we live and it's sort of a pain in
the ass sometimes but it actually is it
like on the weekend I'm sure it's
correct I had like I have to be off of
it I'm forced to and I wouldn't have the
willpower to do that myself
and it is it actually really is great
you know one of my friends JD Vance he
wrote this book hillbilly ology and one
of the things he talks about is he's
like you know we have our best
scientists neuroscientists all these
other people in the world trying to
figure out how does make you and I spend
more micro and milliseconds and kids on
their phones than trying to change the
world or invent medicine like that is
kind of the profit incentive right for
so many of these absolutely that's
something I mean this is a big like new
right conversation actually like Senator
Josh Holley introduced legislation you
got it took a lot of [ __ ] for it cuz
they're like he's trying to be the
product manager of the internet but like
there's something there right there's
something about how these systems are
designed and the people who are working
to try and spend you to make all this
time on the phone yeah I don't know if I
mean that's that's not greately we had
the Surgeon General on our show and he's
like yeah I'm pretty concerned not only
is it not great but it's also really
difficult to avoid oh yeah like once you
get to doing it it's a harder kick than
sugar it's it's right up there with
caffeine and nicotine makes you feel
like you're really doing something it
makes you feel like you're really like
this tweet this one's gonna be that one
that really you know and you watch the
numbers go up and it makes you feel like
you are engaged in some sort of like
minor battle minor victory go to Sam
tripley's Instagram page and pull that
thing that he said what white people
feel like when they virtue signal it is
it's an amazing photograph this district
this to me epitomizes and embodies the
feeling that I get when I see silly
people tweet things yeah
[Laughter]
Khaleesi from Game of Thrones and she's
being carried by all these uh it's this
thing where people just I mean virtue
signal is a [ __ ] fantastic phrase
because it really is what it is yeah
it's just perfect and you know it's a
little overused but I like it I'm gonna
keep using it well it's an important
term too because it explains a lot of
like the ineffectiveness of our politics
like it's all rhetorical it's all like
rhetorically signaling which side you're
on and the sort of illusion of
disagreement in Washington when actually
you know they're a unanimously pass
things like this for trillion dollars
for big business and push everybody mass
unemployment
mathaa my favorite example on that is
there was a like a ten year birthday
party for AIG which is you know the big
insurance try that we bailed out in 2008
in the committee room for the House Ways
and Means which is the committee in
charge of taxing in the United States so
in the committee room they held a
birthday party for the company that they
bailed out Democrats and Republicans all
showed up man the special [ __ ]
specialty cocktails at this thing this
is in the committee room in the very
room to decide where they decided to
bail these companies out which are the
tune of billions you know enduring Wall
Street and so much more thrown birthday
parties well it's all open we were
trying to figure out how Nancy Pelosi
made all our money we're like what's her
husband right is that the thing I think
isn't think so how do you think her dad
was like a shenanigans Dylan Aldrin or
mayor or something I don't know but with
just the amount of money that's involved
in these decisions the amount of money
that's involved in you know an influence
and sharing influence and and getting
people to like your perspective and then
the really gross thing is when they
leave office when politicians
particularly the president leaves office
and then they get these fantastic
paydays to speak here's what anybody
really want to pay to your hillary
clinton speaker just [ __ ] imagine
being the type of person that's like i
got some [ __ ] hot $1500
tickets to hero 50 grand right my
example of this we've covered recently
the former US ambassador to China Max
Baucus he was on you know also Senate
Banking Commission he's now on the board
for Alibaba which is one of the biggest
Chinese companies and then in the middle
of all this stuff around Chinese tariffs
and the coronavirus and all that stuff
he's out there on CNN and on chinese
state media being like trump is Hitler
like do what he's doing
I don't like he was the ambassador to
China and I was getting paid by one of
the largest Chinese companies I mean
which you know in China there's no such
thing really right government and it's
like it's just the it's out in the open
I mean Obama's another great example
Obama is I think is a former NSC
director for cyber security went to go
work for ZTE which is a Chinese
technology I mean for cybersecurity when
to go Lobby is now a lobbyist on behalf
of ZTE it's making we were we were tied
back what you know during Ukraine gate
when we were talking about you know
hunter Biden earning these big paychecks
on this Ukrainian he deserved it that
this is illegal but that's like exactly
the points we have Carson Ted Lou on his
Democrat from California and we're like
you know is this okay it's like people
sit on boards they earn money this is
just because this is they really think
about it that way this is just the way
that the town operates and it's you know
it's easy to look at these individual
examples and be disgusted by them but
the the bottom line is it's a much
deeper problem than that we we covered a
poll recently that was actually done by
the hill and Harris X people's other
number one political issue was
corruption like beyond climate change or
health care or whatever the one the
number one thing that they were most
concerned about was political corruption
and you look at what is happening in the
country right now and the fact that our
institutions have no credibility that
there's no expectation that you could
affect change through traditional
channels I mean that feeds into exactly
the rage that's exploding across the
country we covered before coronavirus
right and 40 million plus Americans
unemployed and hundreds of you know
hundred thousand plus
and before riots broke out and before
George Floyd was killed and before all
of that we covered this poll where 40%
of Americans Athens 43% said when they
think of our cultural and social
institutions they just want to burn it
all down 40% like what does that mean in
a context of a democracy on the other
hand when you consider the fact that the
largest pool of citizens in the country
aren't Trump voters or Hillary voters or
Biden voters or whatever they're non
voters yeah these people have said like
this isn't worth it this doesn't reflect
my this is not going to mean jack [ __ ]
for me in my life and if you look at
that number and then you consider what
you see happening across the country
where people again and they feel like
they have are so disgusted with what's
going on and they're Restless and masked
and like have had all of their normal
tools of being numbed with infotainment
and sugar and all those things and
sports sort of taken away from them you
start to understand what we're seeing
it's really a perfect storm I mean
completely we've never experienced
anything like this before it's
fascinating to see how the thin veneer
of civilization can be chipped through
and you just see the the really deep
pool of despair that's underneath it
it's there's so much madness going on in
the streets today and it's so hard to
get a bead on how this is all playing
out like how it's all being organized
how these cops feel like they can just
shoot people with rubber bullets and
tear gas out in the open front of
everybody when people are I mean you
know ting the death of a guy who was
murdered by a bad cop and where it's on
campus on CNN we're watching live
peaceful protesters
all right reporters getting shot
reporters getting shot get getting her
ass
yes and and to think oh it's just Robert
blows I mean have you seen these wounds
and she's like this is tear gas rubber
bullets flashbang grenades people losing
size her she's actually a friend of mine
Linda really lost her eye yeah yeah wine
in that eyes horrific and you and just a
bead on her because she's she's actually
a really important voice she came to
prominence because she wrote a piece
about the struggle that she had
experienced as a low-income working
class person like just really raw and
honest and that went viral and she from
that was able to write a book and become
a journalist so she's one of the few
journalists voices who actually has any
connectivity to what regular people go
through day to day so you know I mean
it's just like awful to see that sort of
thing happening to her and to so many
others yeah and I mean Joe one of the
things I always appreciate about your
commentary was about about talking about
human violence and like the propensity
to violence and how thin kind of the
veneer of social order and so much of
like what that is and what it actually
means to like live in a society where
whenever you see something like that
breakdown and I've just been thinking
about that so much like in the context
of what we see right now because I mean
it's all so crazy like to see footage of
people just like they feel like they can
just loot with impure right I mean
you're like last night in New York City
it's total destruction I mean there's
there's a giant failure on de Blasio's
part right he's incorporating this
ancient strategy of letting people burn
out this is there's a strategy that they
employed in the 1960s in fact Giuliani
was just talking about this in an
interview the difference between the
wind when he ran New York City you could
say what you want about Giuliani but one
thing he did do is he made it safer he
made New York City a safer place to be
but probably you know the crime rates
did go down across the country in all
cities though not just in New York
during that time that's good but in New
York particularly it was a crime-ridden
City and it went down while he was there
I'm sure across the country had helped
as well but what happened in New York
City was he's letting these people loot
yeah he's telling the cops to stand down
so these businesses that are all
supporting the mayor supporting the tax
and with taxes supporting the police
officers they're watching their
businesses get smashed and looted Fifth
Avenue is destroyed yeah
sixth Avenue destroyed hundreds and
hundreds of buildings with smashed
windows and all their products gone and
then you see but then you also see like
you know police SUVs driving into
protesters and you know tear gassing
indiscriminately so to me it's not a
question of there's a big harder or more
aggressive policing it's the tactics
that make make no sense here's why we're
a discreet protesters should be allowed
to protest right there's a giant
difference between what those people are
doing when they're saying this is
outrageous we need change we need a
radical overhaul of the system right
because there's too many corrupt cops
let those people do what they're doing
but they're not looting see the looters
are different people this is Japan this
has been the hardest thing for Krista
lying to cover like it's funny because
we're coming on here and we were like
and we know all the attention is kind
it's like this there is nothing else
that where the battle lines are so drawn
where frankly there's probably the
biggest difference in our philosophy on
this because I agree with you Jo I mean
I think and I've told this aggressive
which is that the beacon was sent out
when that Minneapolis mayor let that
target go and they let those affordable
housing complexes burn and they let the
police Inc burn that was it and it was
just all across the city and this was an
intentional choice this was out of
political correctness they're like we
don't want to deploy the police because
that would seem like we're impugning
upon these protesters and we're nowhere
and they allowed I mean they allowed
this target and this and it just went
and it caught fire and that's why like
as he said look if people want people
should be able to protest in this
country and if there are piece-of-shit
cops who kick them in the face you know
I've seen terrible videos some of these
things some of the things that they're
doing awful but you can't allow looting
you can't allow this businesses I mean
and this is the thing I wanna Memphis I
mean these look people are like oh you
know it's just property but sometimes
it's corporate property but sometimes
this is a whole guy's life you think
that guy has insurance but you know
here's the thing and why the where
there's such hypocrisy not from Sagar
who's been consistent on this but from
the right in general is like the
response to current a virus lit forty
percent of small businesses on fire
right they didn't care it's
opportunistic caring about it now mostly
from the right and there's also look if
you think about if you think about rule
of law right you think about law and
order and how do you get to a place
where I disagree with you I don't think
it is all different people it's very
easy to be like oh it's Ellen Tifa or
outside shares or whatever I don't think
that's all true
there are certainly criminals who are
opportunistically using the breakdown of
the moment to you know to loot to
vandalize to do whatever that they're
going to do but I think what is harder
to recognize reckon with is that you
have actually quote-unquote ordinary
typically law-abiding people who feel
like the the moment has broken down to
that the extent that they would also
engage in those kinds of acts that's a
harder thing to deal with but when you
think about the moment that we're living
in like the the rules and the laws that
have been set have never been that far
from like that disconnected from what is
moral and what is just if you look at
four trillion to corporations and
everyone else mass unemployment and
small businesses destroyed with when you
look at the fact that of those officers
who murder George Floyd only one of them
has been charged the other three are
still free they haven't been arrested
they've been charged am in anything and
meanwhile you've got you know 4050 of
the legitimacy of rule of law and law
and order that leads to not just outside
ads hairs or white Nash's or Russia or
anti-fur whoever it is that people are
pretending that this is doing all of
this to where you have regular citizens
who are like [ __ ] this I am going to be
out there among them I'm gonna be
defacing our walk
you know in DC I walk by the Department
of the Treasury and it's got black lives
matter scrawled on it right they're
intentionally going the high-end parts
of town like this is actually in many
cases very political and very specific I
think that's a harder thing to have to
reckon with that that dividing line
between these are the good law-abiding
ones and these are the bad ones and
let's just crack down on the bad ones
that line has become very blurry and
that's why it's such an incredibly hard
situation I agree with a lot of what you
said yeah but when we're talking about
protesters and the cops shooting and
attacking protesters you're really
talking about people just standing there
protesting yeah what I'm talking about
is people actually in the act of looting
yeah when they cross that line there's
no justification for smashing into
someone's business and stealing their
goods I understand that people are upset
that four trillion dollars went to these
corporations I think the logic from the
right about this was if we you fund the
corporations and keep them running
they'll employ these people and keep the
society running as smoothly as possible
during this unprecedented pandemic let
me pick up on that Joe because what it
is is that you're right that was the
philosophy but it's often a mistaken one
and there is actually a better option
which is what we talk about so much and
what crystal said which is you're right
from the right there's a lot of concern
trolling around small businesses when
let's be honest they allowed a cap to
the White House I mean advisors or
Senate Republicans allowed a cap to be
put on the Paycheck protection program
which was for small businesses they
allowed that to go capped and allowed it
to go dry and had political fights about
it there was always been an option to
put you know this is a right-left thing
senator Josh Holley senator Cory Gardner
and I think it's congresswoman Pramila
jeyapaul they have plans to put
Americans on their payroll to have the
federal government subsidize that
payroll up until until the end of this
Great Depression and in that way you
keep businesses together right you keep
businesses you have they have the
Paycheck protection program you have the
workers they aren't to go on
unemployment or anything and you can
scale that up and no business has to go
out they don't have to fail they don't
have to do all this so for me this
shemitah houses 40 million plus an
employee being employed we had an
intentional government policy of
unemployment that was our policy was
like let's have millions math okay what
would you rather
do if you have a pandemic that look what
it turned out to be was a big difference
from what we thought it was going to be
I was very different we thought I was
gonna kill 10% of the people we thought
it's gonna be a devastating pandemic
that was gonna sweep through the country
and all our friends were going to die
that's we thought right turns out to not
be the case we're lucky well in in some
ways when they were trying to figure out
a way to mitigate this situation yeah
they decided we're gonna shut down
society right because we want to protect
lives over money right what would you
have done well the alternative look
there was always going to be pain
there's no doubt about that and you
can't you know legislate away from that
but other countries did it much better
and they spent less money where they
essentially nationalize payrolls so
people stay attached to their jobs but
they don't they aren't going in it is
still shut down what countries did it's
much smaller countries right yeah
certainly but actually in terms of their
percent of GDP and all that yeah it
could have been it could have been done
much much but they did it for the
airlines so the airline bailout which
was custom written included a provision
that you have to keep your workers and
so we're gonna give you this money and
basically backstop payroll and so look I
mean they're messing around and then as
soon as the sends they want to still lay
people off but if you backstop the
payroll and essentially nationalize it
especially in our country where your
health insurance is tied to your job so
now not only do have people are
unemployed but they're losing their
health insurance during a pandemic that
just compounds everything and it is
absolutely unconscionable meanwhile you
know Galatz of big corporations got like
custom written legislation for
themselves and 40% of small businesses
told the Chamber of Commerce that they
will be closing their doors of the next
six in terms of the cost I'm fairly
certain that Pramila jeyapaul one over
three months was six hundred billion so
yeah it's a lot of money but you know
three you know 2.3 trillion was the
first one extra couple hundred billion
for the paycheck protection program in
the scale of what we did is especially
we include the four trillion with the
Federal Reserve the money was not the
problem that money is not this is an
issue of political will is this
something that could have been agreed
upon by both parties is there something
that could have gone through by the
corporate left in the corporate right no
way so what would you have done see if
you had a magic wand and you were the
president like how do you how do you
mitigate this how do you
this is my biggest frustration with the
White House which is that you have this
populist president who like actually
understands like very much why he got
elected but you have so many you has all
these people who work for him from kind
of the old regime basically was allowed
to staff up and those are the people who
were like let's cap the Paycheck
protection program who are like hey you
know we just passed this to this two
point three trillion dollar plan or what
this well let's look wait and see how it
goes as the you know the unemployment
numbers began to take up mass small
business failure all these other things
and that's the fundamental tension of
the Trump administration is that there
was no like there were no professional
populace so to speak right like there
was no professional apparatus of people
on the right who actually held and
understood why Donald Trump is president
states and this is like this is what
gets back to what I talked about earlier
about the incentive structure about that
system the think tank the revolving door
that is an effort to maintain power over
the policy sphere because if you control
that it doesn't matter what the people
think yeah yeah I mean he matters what
happened here's here's why I was because
I mean look he's the president and he
makes his own choices and if he
understood like that there was this need
to go more economically left and do it
then he could he could do it but the
reality is he spent his whole most of
political capital his first term like
giving a wave tax cuts to corporations
the same thing any other Republican
would have done so that's why I sort of
roll my eyes I don't think he cares
about anything outside of like winning
the day's news cycle I really don't
think he gives a [ __ ] about anything
other than that you know I mean see this
is this is the thing though I mean I've
met Trump have interviewed him a couple
of times for five to four times I think
and what does he like exactly what you
see exactly what you see on TV
same guy do you feel like you got
through the layers to talk to a human ya
know because he's always you know my
favorite thing I ever asked Trump I was
like what are people gonna remember you
for in a hundred years
and he's a veteran's choice and I was
like I'm gonna go out on a limb that's
probably not it right Jesus I'm like
sitting in there
I occurred with Mema Trump like I'm in
the oval and like you're like man that's
sort of like Kissinger was sitting like
man that's the JFK picture and like
Eisenhower least I don't think he thinks
about any of them what did he mean by
veterans choice that he chose the
veterans to know that he was taking care
of veterans through like a veteran's
health care going off like why he would
you know like all his basically like the
talking points like why he's great but
but I realized I'm like Trump lives
completely in the moment and he doesn't
really have that like he doesn't really
think about things in that historical
context well this is faster than the
briefings
he pays attention if his name's brought
up they throw his name in there every
now and again I feel like we deserve him
and he's the perfect present for this
time think think about I think you're so
right and to make it like a not a
partisan thing our politics are so
shallow hollow theatre cable news base
they're like Twitter politics and you
can see it not just with Trump who's
like the ultimate incarnation of that
but during this pandemic Andrew Cuomo is
like the celebrity governor Democrats
are like we gotta get him in there he's
amazing he's your New York had the worst
outbreak of any state and that's not all
on him but it is partly on him how was
it so let me tell you a couple things
yes in part yes but also they shut down
later right then other places like
Washington like California which had
much lower outbreak he mandated that
nursing homes take back in 43 percent of
coronavirus deaths are nursing homes
this is a nursing home panic mandated
that they take back in recovering kovat
patients and he happens that he got a
you know million dollar plus campaign
check for his re-election through
affiliated committee before he got
reelected and so he also put made sure
to put into place a liability for all
their executives so if they don't do a
good job that can't be held liable and
that data shows is correlated with
increased
vyd death and infection rates because
they know that they're not gonna be held
responsible so there's a lower threshold
there so there were very specific
decisions that were really bad and
fueled the worst outbreak in the entire
country but because you can get on TV
and give a command and press conference
that's all people really care about he's
got like 80% approval ratings yeah has
he spoken about the recovering kovat
patients being readmitted to the nursing
homes not much because his brother
on CNN is prime time anchor Chris Cuomo
and they do these ridiculous interviews
where they like joke around about how
big as noses rather than asking
questions like that and look it'd be one
thing if you were gonna have your
brother on once or twice funny you know
but no night after night after night
it's the show of the two brothers
chumming it up while people are dying
this is a politician who's supposed to
be held to account that is the police to
be rolling around with his brother
joking about the size of their nose in
the swab well there are like literally
thousands of elderly people who died
because explicitly because of this
decision now we're not saying nuweiba
decision but like there needs to be some
like scrutiny and accountability of that
nobody at CNN wants to touch it because
Chris Cuomo is the anchor nobody at
MSNBC wants to touch it because he's the
biggest Democrat and they all live in
New York and they all probably had
dinner with each other and of course I
mean people on the right are talking
about it because he's a Democrat but
there's no I mean outside Bristol and a
few others on the left you all right and
on the right they're total hypocrites to
Fox News picks it up with this like
liability story and how he gets this
through meanwhile Mitch McConnell's
proposing the same thing at a national
level and they're like a ok with that so
I mean this gets back to the sort of
central concept of the show we just hope
we don't do that shape you know like you
[ __ ] up on this thing like let's talk
about it if it's a Republican we're
gonna do the same thing and that's the
way I mean on a basic level that's
always supposed to be and it it's a big
big problem again going back to this
moment that we're living in because no
one trusts anyone for good reason even
if you are an MSNBC watcher and you know
it and you love it and you love Rachel
Maddow and whatever you know you're
getting spun you know that they're
taking certain stories that are gonna
like pique your interest and they're
ignore
but the end of every the lesson of every
single news story cannot be ergo Trump
is bad like that cannot be the
conclusion of literally every news story
and over on fox news the end conclusion
of every news story cannot be ergo
democrats are evil and unamerican
right every week we all know this no
people are not that stupid no they're
not and I couldn't agree more and that's
one of the things I find very refreshing
about your show is that you guys don't
exhibit that kind of partisanship you
just say what you think people are
[ __ ] up you say I have one old phone
that I could check it really four or
five days yeah and then my phone that I
connect with with friends just that
[ __ ] thing moves around smart very
wise I just think that you have to
develop strategies to protect your
consciousness you know you really do
well especially your level I can't
imagine it's it's unmanageable so I
don't manage it just keep moving
let's keep moving stay busy yeah stay
busy and don't take yourself seriously
and just keep moving yes yeah I feel
like there's a real movement towards
what you guys are doing though I feel
like it's the future because I feel like
people are fed up with that Chris Cuomo
[ __ ] they're fed up with that Rachel
Maddow [ __ ] and no disrespect to either
one of those those people but like I was
with Chris Cuomo was doing some thing in
the day and I was watching him where
he's basically justifying riots yeah and
I was like how man did someone write
this for you is this how you really feel
did you think this out for this I think
I've all I could get from that is Trump
needs to be removed from office
so let's come up with some sort of a
reason why he's responsible for these
riots and these riots are good and these
rides have been historically done when
people feel powerless and weak that's
all true
I look it's it's a terrible position to
be a young person right now and this is
what you see when you're seeing looting
you see a lot of these [ __ ] young
white kids that have probably not a
political thought and they're [ __ ]
dopey heads and they just run in to get
free Nikes and that's really what's
going on yeah I've watched about a
hundred videos of people looting I might
have seen four black people it's all
white kids stealing sneakers so it's
kind of amazing right and this is I mean
this is what really gets me which is
that this is a pro George Floyd's family
has come out and said please stop
violence keys I mean how many times you
see that well you remember Rodney King
yeah can we all get along and I think I
think that's like that peace
understanding who and why is important
to understanding what to do
right because if it's just what I have
seen hasn't just been you know in terms
of looting I don't know specifically but
I think it's very easy to say oh it's
just this type of person it's just that
type of person and to take out of it any
of the sort of like more radical not
just smashing up stores and that kind of
stuff but like graffiti and more you
know defying curfews and those sorts of
things and so if if you view the problem
is just like violent protesters we have
to deal with that then that merits one
response and that's the direction the
Trump is going in is like call in the
military which i think is [ __ ] scary
like calling in active-duty military in
every city in the country like we saw
with the protesters who got you know the
tear gas and rubber bullets in front of
the White House or peacefully protest I
mean that [ __ ] to me is scary and
frankly the fact that Democrats and
quote-unquote journalists on TV have
acted like the world is ending
every time Trump does anything when he
does do something like invoke the
insurrection act and say we're looking
at sending the military into American
cities there is no more language of this
is unprecedented this is outrageous this
is you know different than what we've
seen in the past left because they've
burned that up once the critical thing
that that Trump has ever done they have
cried you that's exactly the case
because I do think that this is a
very different and very dangerous and
volatile moment but if you think that
the protests are about the the structure
of a system that doesn't allow any
redress for you know problems that
people have been peacefully protesting
about for a long [ __ ] time and not a
thing has been done if you think the
protests are about you know political
system that will offer you the
quote-unquote choice of Donald Trump
who's like the Central Park five dude
and red lighting with his daddy and
denying black people housing and
Charlottesville's find people on both
sides versus Joe Biden who wrote the 94
crime bill is unrepentant for it
it was justifying against with
Charlamagne just recently and saying
Hillary's wrong to apologize it for it
etcetera etcetera who as part of this
whole thing went out and said you know
police shouldn't be shooting people in
the heart and said they should shoot him
in the leg like train him to do that
like when you look at those two choices
you [ __ ] choices this that's right if
you understand that as the legitimate
part of the protest then your response
is going to be very different than it's
just like oh these are bad people these
are people wish además terrorists we
have to crack down on them let's call in
the military that [ __ ] ultimately never
works because look at 19 years in
Afghanistan what do we learn yeah you
can take the ground
you can't hold it you can't hold a
society together with an aggressive
militarized
response that's not gonna work over time
so if that's your only strategies like
okay then what then what are you gonna
do or we have curfews at 1:00 p.m. every
day our you know military's holding down
American cities every day because you
have a significant chunk of the
population that will no longer consent
so I think that I think on this
particular one this is probably where we
disagree the most because and and she
pointed this out which is that to me
it's about the restoration of law and
order and and look I mean this is why
you saw these see aunt joy read right I
mean these people were putting out
conspiracy theories that action so what
here's what have I done oh what that is
which is we'll begin with the timeline
which is that the timeline was you know
at first the Minneapolis the target got
looted you know the affordable housing
complex went down everybody decided okay
violence looting everything is fine so
they're basically justifying it on cable
then what happened is a second night
happened
a lot more violence and protests were
police and firefighters weren't visible
so Minnesota authorities started lying
about how actually every single person
arrested was out of state not true local
news went and they found these poor
mayor st. Paul mentioned on camera and
said every one of the people that was
arrested was did not have a Minnesota
address that was a blatant [ __ ] ID
for some of them were from the town and
here's this so why is it why is it that
because then they start laundering
through joy read at MSNBC that it's
actually a bunch of Russians and white
nationalists I [ __ ] you not
you can pull you and how was that lady
still on TV oh especially with their
blog post but the real thing again if
you are wrong in ways that it's okay the
reason I'm burying up Reid is because
the legitimacy for the use of force for
these people it only applies if it's
Russians or white nationalists you're
allowed to crack down on that whereas so
look on the military front let's think
about our history Eisenhower 1957 calls
in 101st Airborne Division in order to
forcibly integrate Little Rock High
School to stop to allow the Little Rock
Nine tend to that school because a white
supremacist violent mob and the local
authorities could not be trusted to do
so I think that's a legitimate use 1967
f LBJ calls in the military to race
riots in Detroit I think that's
legitimate Rodney King George HW Bush
calls in the Marines in order restore
order you have to restore and crack down
exactly on the people we're talking
about these criminals a lot of more
sociopaths and criminals just taking
advantage of this situation and from
that forward we have to move and act
within the political system now crystal
seems to think I think that acting
within the political system is just not
a choice at this point but I disagree
because I mean even if you're on the
Left like Joe Biden out today saying he
endorses this Hakeem Jeffries bill on
banning police chokehold right why but
why is anyone paying attention right now
I'm not talking about violence and by
the way majority's violence I've been
saying has been coming from the cops and
there's never as much focus the example
of you know that could send you some
video teaser I mean I've seen some stuff
to you and
I'm justifying anything but I've also
seen some unconscionable tactics from
the police one person and there's no
focus anytime on that I've seen police
inciting and creating the dangerous
situation do I have any confidence that
given what we saw on TV with the
military police coming in and tear
gassing and rubber bullets put peaceful
populations that this is going to
they're gonna go come in as peacekeepers
in these stated cities absolutely not if
you bring the military in you were
starting a war you're not ending
violence you're escalating violence and
that's the thing let me ask you this I
think local law enforcement I mean if
the cities aren't up to it fine they can
call in the National Guard but well
that's the military for the President to
bring in the American military into
cities across the country without local
consent I think it's insane and is only
saying that if they don't use the
National Guard think about the context
of if you saw this happening in other
country right it's it's hard to like
look at our own country through you know
neutral lens if you looked at a foreign
country and you heard that their
president was bringing in the military
to quash protesters would you be like oh
this is gonna go great no he's not
bringing the military squash protesters
bringing the military stop how can you
see the difference but how can you say
that when we see TV just shooting rubber
bullets and tear gas at peaceful
protesters we're not supporting that
right we're talking about what's going
on in New York City you stop people from
breaking into law-abiding people do that
that's what we're saying the military
agreement them even using the National
Guard isn't trained to do that that
isn't what the other way we don't have
the military do local law enforcement I
mean one of the big problems of local
law enforcement has actually been the
militarization which occurred after 9/11
which occurred under Barack Obama as
well when you roll tanks into American
streets and you treat the citizens like
this is a war you escalate the violence
so my point is if you are opposed to the
violence sending in the military is
exactly the wrong thing to do yes people
shouldn't what people should have their
property protected but you're you're not
saying what the right thing to
to us better policing media police are
going to have to do the same thing that
the National Guard would do arrest
people for smashing windows and breaking
into buildings they just might have the
resources to handle something on the
scale that you're seeing in Manhattan
see I think this is where this is this
is the issue which is that when people
like you and I who are against police
violence who are against and acknowledge
this action we have a solution these
people should be fired and should be
enquiries on that yes but there's no
solution than I hear from the left on
how do you stop rioting and looting when
the governor of the state of New York
refuses to act I'll give you a solution
okay but there's in the immediate term
there's no D you can de-escalate the
situation all the Trump is doing right
now by calling for the military and
create create strain is in a war zone is
escalating the violence and radicalized
yes so for example and I know this
sounds hokey but this is true if he had
come out last night instead of having
military police shooting tear gas and
rubber bullets and flashbang grenades
and crushing these protesters if he had
come out with that same cast characters
bill Barr and whoever else was with him
and taken money for 8 minutes and 45
seconds the amount of time that you know
George Floyd had that knee on his neck
until he does write us he can't do that
and then if he had instead of saying I'm
gonna send the military in and crush
these protesters and by the way he's
deeming them terrorists right our fellow
citizens he's saying these are
terrorists if he had instead offered
actual like no one's gonna solve this
problem overnight but you can offer a
few pieces of legislation or at least an
Alf branch then you start to de-escalate
rather than radicalizing rather than
rather than going the police state
military state way which never ends well
I mean give me an example over say when
does this ever end well okay well you
never hold on we've never had this
before we've never had people smashing
windows all down Manhattan you look at
Fifth Avenue is insane right now it
looks like a bomb went off and shattered
every window within five city blocks I
go back to our history Joe because we
have done this before MLK and DC called
in 13,000 troops in order to but I'm
saying it has like use again like the
military does
law whenever these local authorities
refused to do it and look in the
immediate term like first of all I mean
I don't think and the left would give
him a heavy credit whatsoever if he did
you know do any of what was just
suggested there but second which is that
this is just the fundamental difference
conservative and liberal disposition
which is that there are some bad people
out there who you can show them as much
compassion as you want they're still
going to loot and fall they're still
gonna loot they're still going to
criminalize there's no such thing as
like de-escalation in the in the most
near term when people are actively as
you said looting the streets of New York
and so if the governor of the state of
New York refuses to call these if these
states and these like I said police not
the governor's the mayor so the mayor
and I think the government actually
wants to remove the may displace this is
the thing about may you know the
Minnesota the Minnesota police and and
all of that which is that they refused
out of political correctness in order to
crack down immediately upon people who
work the very small group of people who
are violent criminals that's what
allowed this thing to go national and
now people are and this is it's part of
our history we have done it before
and again labor look after the after the
El Paso shooting I heard all from the
left all of a sudden we need the FBI in
order to crack down on the I agree I
think that these violent white
supremacist organizations should be
taken down and if they're out there
marching and they're committing violence
they should absolutely be knocked out
and this is the point which is where I
pointed to why they started to blame
Russians and white Nationals because
they realized this was going against
them they only view it as legitimate
whenever they're using force to quash
aside which is not which is that they
agree with and that they don't do it
whenever it's a political cause they do
but that thing is happening which is
right though which is the one second is
this is selective application of justice
and this is exactly what they're worried
about which is that I have a better idea
you enforce the rule of law and law and
order against violent white supremacists
and against violent looting criminals
who take advantage of a legitimate
protest against the horrific death of so
I think that's part of where the
breakdown in our views occurs because I
think it's fantasy
I think it's fantasy to a mad
that you could trust this president to
deploy force in a responsible way and
we've already seen that like that's not
it's not a debatable point because we've
already seen him abused that force with
peaceful protesters and by the way the
First Amendment is also a sacred right
that is part of why I loved this country
that should be protected which is being
overwhelmingly quashed by force right
now in this country by bad policing by
you know this president and what he did
with those peaceful protesters and the
idea that bringing the military in is
going to de-escalate is going to solve
the problem I think that's just a
fantasy look I don't know that you know
I don't know that the response to the
Rodney King riots or to the 68 riots is
really the thing to emulate either and
the question again is not is it good to
lewd is it good to of course not no one
is saying that my question is what then
let's say you bring in the quash and
like you put what then what then there's
no there is no plan for how do we we've
had these debates we've had these
marches we've had the outrage we've had
all of it and it never ever changes and
so you got a lot of people out there
doing [ __ ] that they shouldn't be doing
but they feel like finally all are
paying attention I'm statistically
history in the country statistically it
is changing statistically there's less
people getting shot and killed by cops
than ever before that that statistically
I believe that all these protests and
all these people but I'm not just
talking about police brutality because I
see the the policing issue as existing
within a much larger problem which is a
society that dehumanizes which is a
society that is cruel I mean it's sort
of like what we're talking about on on
social be the good people and the bad
people and we've divided society like
the worthy people who are treated like
human beings people like us so ever
needs cater to it and are like
emotionally like coddled and all of that
and people who are treated like less
than and those people are
disproportionately black and brown but
that's the underclass of America that is
more when I'm talking to and the
policing system that we have is to
protect
this group and to police that group and
that's the part that has not changed I
mean we see we see the vast inequality
we see the people who are now laid off
who don't have hope in their life that
things are going to be better for their
kids than it is for them and that's the
piece that I'm talking about so yeah
bring in the military quash and put a
gun to their head you know put a curfew
at 1 p.m. lock down the country you
might solve the problem of looting the
Gucci outlet right but what then where
do you go from there and that's the part
and I'm not on the piece with with Trump
and they're like he's doing the same
thing in terms of saying oh this is all
an Tifa and they're all terrorists and
that justifies these kinds of actions
and to me that is what is truly scary
because if you really were saying let's
just go after the bad ones and you had
someone that you really choke a maybe
that's one thing but that you're trying
to paint everyone who is involved in
these protests as essentially other as
essentially terrorists that to me is
what is terrifying well I think he
actually addressed it saying that
there's people that are protesting that
have a legitimate concern and that this
is a real issue and the real problem
that happened and huge people to stop
the lawless behavior right where it has
nothing to do with George Floyd they're
just smashing windows and stealing
things on a split screen wit like he's
saying those words on a split screen
with military police cracking down on
regular peaceful hundred percent
preschool protesters like you and I are
in agreement with peaceful protesters
yeah we all in agreement protest
actually I don't think there's anything
wrong with it I think it's a great thing
and I think that just a high-profile
nature of this should raise awareness
and hopefully these police
administrators and the people that are
in charge are gonna get their [ __ ]
together and get rid of these bad cops
right when you see this guy who did this
is George Floyd you realize this guy's
had a decade and this loss that's my
complaints against him there are similar
shooting people assaulting people you
know ok this is let's let's think about
this too which is that from the very
beginning I think the left is blown is
so badly Sean Hannity Rush Limbaugh and
Donald Trump all universally agreed that
what
happened to George Floyd was that that
cop was a criminal I've never seen one
person say exactly and yet immediately
it devolves into approach and protest
fine protest because that county
prosecutor did not file a charge against
George Floyd the cop who killed George
Floyd immediately and that is what
sparked the initial protest there is
absolutely nothing wrong with that
protest but then the line became let's
justify the rioting and the looting
let's tell you where we're not
necessarily ok with it but it's part of
a broader systemic critique and then of
course America revolted against that
right now at the polling just came out
right before we here 58 percent of
Americans say they support using the
military to supplement police force this
you know I mean I'm a populist one of
the things I think about so much more in
my politics 50 plus 1 solutions what are
50 plus 1 solutions that we can get to
on economics that we can get to about
our immigration system about trade about
the way we order our society and I'm
against the elites who pushed down upon
the majority and use their corporate
influence in order to pass against that
58 percent of Americans right now are
asked are basically completely support
using the military in order to
supplement police effort because they
understand that what is happening right
now is unconscionable and even let's
take a purely working-class issue of
this which is that I saw a video of a
crying elderly American black elderly
black American woman talking about these
protesters burned down my grocery store
they burned down everywhere I shop she
even said I would rather be where George
is right now talking about George Floyd
because of what happened to her I mean
we have seen these homeless a homeless
man in Austin whose mattress was just
needlessly burned by these criminals in
fringes to taunt him just we've seen
both in business owners who have been
beaten savagely beaten by looting
criminals with no police presence that
is not that this shows you that the
establishment of law and order and
keeping law and order is a benefit one
of the ways that we protect the most
vulnerable in our population and the
most vulnerable in our population are
working-class Americans they're the ones
have to clean this [ __ ] up by the way
like I drove through you know DC it was
I ride my scooter going around there
through the and I see all these
working-class merc with the you know
they have to take the glass they have to
put the board's up who are the people
who are not being able to go to work
right now after we just had the worst
economic crisis are still in the midst
of the worst economic crisis since the
Great Depression so justification of
rioting and looting and the destruction
of the small businesses and not having a
way in order to deal with that is anti
working-class but beyond that crystal
asked a great question which is okay so
after what do we do and this is where
you're right which is the right does not
agree the right the right just wants to
stop it but no 50% of black Americans
right now do not have a job in this
country because of the explicit choice
made by Senate Democrats and Senate
Republicans not to adopt the payroll
program that we are right now it's never
been at a better time in America to go
and to look at that payroll production
program and I really encourage people in
order to go in to look at that proposal
because I don't think it's gotten nearly
enough attention and not enough
Republicans and Democrats are being
pressed on whether they support
something like that so here's my
solution yeah we have the you know we
restore order in America and then we
need to make sure that people are taking
care of not through just distributed non
unemployment benefits but through
actually having putting these businesses
making them hole through a paycheck
protection program using you know the
halle plan in order to do eighty percent
of American workers payroll so they can
go back and remain intact and then we
can scale that up with the reopening
because I think you were talking about
this here on the podcasts like these
restaurants right like restaurant
businesses even in the best of times 100
percent capacity is [ __ ] hard to run
around right and limited the problem is
that it's not gonna happen
I mean [ __ ] are Mitch McConnell's
already like we're not coming back we're
not doing anything else I mean that and
that's really where we're stuck like I'm
not trying to adjust it for like but
that sort of stuff is absolutely
unconscionable like smashing up some one
small business that they've worked on
absolutely unaccepting
absolutely unacceptable I don't want to
ignore the fact that much of the
violence I have seen has come from cops
which is why I think bringing in the
military only increases the level of
violence but that's where things are so
stuck I think dr. Cornel West who I know
you had on I love that program by the
way that you did with him
love him he said we are living in
America as a failed social experiment
his failed to provide for the economic
health and dignity needs of its citizens
and so yes
figure out how to deal with the the
violent elements and and yet it peaceful
etc but the idea that you're going to
crack down and take the pressure off and
then the change is gonna happen that's
not gonna happen and it's why we are
truly stuck because you have such a
large percent of the population which
does feel that nihilistic which does
feel like the choices on the bat you
know go vote like President Obama he's
always say don't boo vote like we
they've been doing that and it hasn't
really changed their material outcomes
for their life that's a part of the show
that I think we more or less agree on is
like how little choice is offered to
people in terms of actually improving
their material well-being and having
their interests looked out for by
Washington DC and so yeah when you push
people that far with 40 percent say burn
it all down it's a it's you are asking
for exactly the tinderbox that were
saying right 40 percent of people
willing to answer polls most people like
I'm busy I have [ __ ] to do but the
people ISM that I see some so much of
that element of the left in particular
like Cornell what the failed social
experiment it just ignores like that
extraordinary things can happen through
political change and even if they do
want political change like a friend of
our show said Gilani
I mean heat side of these studies coming
out of 1968 where you can see explicitly
that nonviolent protests dramatically
increased support for the civil rights
movement and that whenever it would turn
violent that it would turn against them
and that in in one study in particular
showed that it led to the election of
Richard Nixon which is something but I
don't see that the protesters are
violent violent like the the association
of the violence yes the protest movement
I think it's just opportunists that are
taking
think there's a giant percentage of
what's going on as opportunities taking
advantage of this movement in the chaos
I totally agree I feel like what Cornel
West is saying one of the reasons why it
resonates is if they have so much money
for the bailouts they have so much money
to take care of people during covet for
these corporations so much money to deal
with this why didn't they invest that
money in fixing all these problems that
have happened in these cities that have
had a long deep history of economic
problems yes I mean you know I lived in
Kentucky and Appalachian Lake choice
like make it Universal so everybody buys
in but that's exactly I mean we had this
whole Democratic primary and every
debate it was like well how are you
gonna pay for it but then the moment
that the stock market crashed it was
like here's four trillion dollars good
shot
so it just exposes that's that's part of
the moment that we have done or stands
it just exposes the fact that all of
this idea that we can do anything to
help you and I'm so sorry there's not
money and that the system is
fundamentally fair has been completely
exposed as a lie the fit system has
never been fundamentally fair but people
have tried their best to make it as fair
as possible while supporting the special
interest group that put them into power
while trying to keep up with the demands
their constituents it's a mess one of my
favorite things I talk about is what
crystal and I really want to try and do
or especially for me is I want to make
it the cynical choice in order to do the
right thing that's the hardest game in
politics because that's what the special
interested right like you it's the
cynical choice in order to pass the
subsidy or do the bailout for acts and
not for why because you know you're
gonna get a job out on the other side or
you know that you're gonna benefit
politically that's what we need to do we
need to make it so that it's the cynical
choice to show up for working-class
people and right now I mean that's one
of the things I really took note of
which this Holly plan I'm talking about
Cory Gardner from Colorado is the most
vulnerable Republican in the United
States Senate and he's signed on to that
plan now he's running for reelection he
was he was vulnerable for all of us even
happened and I would that's him that's
what you can try and capitalize on you
can show people even if they're the most
cynical Act I don't know anything about
Cory I don't know why so I just want to
make it clear but like if you can make
it
that it's the cynical choice to try and
show up now that is an extraordinarily
hard thing to do that is I'm not gonna
sit here and pretend as if I don't talk
about every single day about how the
system is rigged in the political system
in particular and who owns who but it
there this is part of what I think we're
on to about what like what the heterodox
kind of space which is that there is an
extraordinary support for efforts like
this and if you can show these
politicians if you do something like
this you will get praise from crystal
and sagar you will get an electoral
benefit you will have the media it what
this is the keys you need to build
alternative ecosystem centers of power
which are able to elevate that so that
they know that they have somebody who's
gonna have their back because right now
if you go you know the standard line
they're always gonna have right or the
left to back you up at a time of crisis
you'll have the money people will
fundraise do you have to show people
that by doing the right thing that
that's where the best politics are and
that's what we focus on in terms of the
economic solutions and so much of what
we advocate for on the show is to show
people like I said 50 plus one solutions
exist there is political opportunism to
be had by just doing the right thing
this was Trump I mean Trump's like
innovation more than anything was
running against standard GOP ideology in
the 2016 primary run you know running on
trade saying no maybe trades not always
a good thing running hard on immigration
which is something GOP voters have
always wanted those two issues in
particular went completely against Paul
Ryan and so much of what they were
advocating for but you could never say
it because if you said it not gonna get
on Fox if you didn't if you said it
you're not gonna be in leadership the
you know the Republicans aren't gonna
fund raise money for you you know think
tanks collar is gonna write fake studies
and fake papers about how you're a liar
that's exactly what he exposed that
there's opportunity to be had there what
we got to do is build up media and
alternative organizations which show
people that there is a cynic there is a
way to be cynical there is a way because
people are cynical people politicians in
particular there is a way to act in your
own self-interest and to do the right
thing and I think that that's why I've
looked at it as much more of a I don't
look at it then that nihilistic way I
look at it in a much more positive way
which is the
this did happen I mean something broke
through and I'm not I don't think it's
been perfect but it's something which we
can capitalize on and build over decades
because I think God knows I mean people
need it right now it's the worst
economic crisis this is a Great
Depression well I think were you and I
agree is that law and order needs to be
re-established and one of the reasons
why I think that it needs to be
reestablished is there's a fire of
consciousness and this fire is you're
allowed to loot and smash and steal and
people are doing that now and I don't
think they're doing it in the memory of
George Floyd and I think you got to put
that fire out because once you allow
people to do it like the Blasio did in
New York City and force the police to
stand back people know they can get away
with it I've seen some horrific things
people running over people with cars and
smashing into buildings and it's [ __ ]
madness when madness happens you have to
crackdown you have to do something about
it that's where I support whether it's
the National Guard or if the police have
the resources use the police but
something has to be done when you're
saying like president Trump
de-escalating on television that is not
going to do a goddamn thing about those
kids smashing windows it's not going to
change their attitude they're not
watching the news they're not paying
attention they know they have a very
simplistic perspective George Floyd this
is bad black lives matter chaos smashed
that window take that [ __ ] they're not
gonna say hey you know when Trump got on
his knees I was going to loot Gucci but
I'm not gonna do that anymore like that
there's both fake [ __ ] on both sides
yeah here's got to do something to stop
the fire you got to put that fire out
then deescalate
but first the fire has to stop because
there's a it's an obvious mob mentality
thing because no one's ever seen this
before no one's and there's a Santa
Monica who's you got running around with
a gun pointing it at people
people are driving into [ __ ] people
and knocking them over it's crazy not
something that anyone expected seven
days ago and [ __ ] and it is a sign of
like a breakdown of a society it's like
they're storm there's no despair from
three months of not working is
unprecedented
you've never at a time where through no
fault of your own you are broke you
can't pay for food you can't pay your
mortgage you can't pay your rent
you're [ __ ] and there's no jobs I had
it's not like there's anything these
kids can go out and do
to better their position the amount of
jobs that existed just three months ago
it's drastically reduced so there are
opportunities which are already slim to
none have you know we're talking about
people getting out of college in 2020
that how bad their economic
opportunities are before all this
comparison too much how about if you're
coming out of high school yes and aren't
gonna go to college I mean most people
don't go to college right and so a
people missing smash my only my only
point is that the military is not a
solution is the solution though well the
solution is to actually do something
about the material condition ultimately
right now there's a solution about the
fire how do you put out the fire because
there's a fire when these people are
smashing windows all down Fifth Avenue
that's a fire right but I think where we
view it differently is that in my view
the tactics the aggressive tactics that
the police have used have only made that
worse no no right so my view is if you
bring in the military first of all I
find it I find all of I think we are
getting far too comfortable and this is
partly part of the perfect storm with
the pandemic like we've become very
comfortable with all these extreme
limitations on our actions behavior
wearing the masks in public which
creates a level of anonymity like all of
that goes into this so when when we have
a curfew imposed of 1 p.m. or 5 p.m. or
6 p.m. we're just good to go with that
but that should be taken in and of
itself very seriously as an infringement
on First Amendment rights I agree
so my point is that if you bring in the
military it is frightening in terms of
our liberties our ability to protest our
First Amendment rights which are
incredibly important and I think
ultimately only leads to additional
violence yeah things going around in
circles here because I agree with you on
all those things and I am a hundred
percent in support of the people
protesting right people that are walking
on the street with signs about George
Floyd and black lives matter I'm a
hundred percent in favor of that it's
the looting so how do you stop the
looting you've got to do something to
stop the looting if you don't stop the
looting it is going to [ __ ] continue
stop tear gassing protesters and start
focusing on
don't think so they started tear gassing
protestors after the looting after all
that [ __ ] got crazy that's when they
started cracking down on the protest I
think it's a mistake because I don't
think they're connected I think the
people that are doing all the looting
and the Smashing are not the people that
are peacefully protesting and there's a
ton of videos of people who were
screaming it but there's a one video of
this girl who's yelling at these these
girls in front of a Starbucks that are
spray-painting black lives matter it's
an african-american girl and these white
girls white that look that's a huge part
of this whole thing which is that
there's just upper middle class white
liberalism and their inability I mean
just as a whole element of white guilt
and so much more there's an entire
industrial industrial complex set up to
make white people and upper middle class
white people in particular feel
uncomfortable condemning looting and
violence in this particular scenario
even though everybody agrees with you
Joe I mean pretty much everybody is like
yeah protests are fine looting is bad
protests are been great right and what
happened to George Floyd was [ __ ] up
that's like 1 2 3 95% of people in this
in this country would agree with
something like that and so that's why I
think that that I mean look at and that
shows you that there is again a
political way to be forged here which is
like like you said nobody thinks that
this nobody was defending George Floyd
no one I mean like Rush Limbaugh and
Sean I just thought this whole thing
about Sean Hannity was like you know the
mark as a martial artist like putting
his hold on the neck right stop right
don't say that don't say what would you
recommend for kids want to get it
jujitsu because there's no head trauma
or very little is that a CTE like a
thing you know
for sure
my all-time functional Wow yeah if
you've been hitting the head a bunch of
times you most likely have it I mean
from the time I was fifteen till I was
21 22 I was hit in the head almost every
day like there's no getting around it
you didn't get some form of brain damage
how come there's not like a backlash
against it like with the NFL well there
is I mean it's more internal it's like I
feel like the NFL it's it's more
prevalent and I think that the impacts
are more devastating when I watch those
huge super athletes running at full clip
and slamming into each other it's a
[ __ ] car accident right and it's a
car accident multiple times a week and
these guys are doing well they were
taking those big hits and training as
well but there was a study on football
players that found that between they
tested high school all the way up to NFL
and they said there was some staggering
number of people that had CTE including
high school kids
Wow like if you had a son would you
learn no [ __ ] way but I'd let them
fight let me fight teach them how to
fight correctly I would say look at you
want to do this this is dangerous as
[ __ ] but you can do it and there's great
benefit in knowing how to fight there's
a giant benefit if someone's trying to
assault you and they don't know how to
fight and you do it's huge isn't it a
UFC fighter who was going who was like
helping out with some of the looting or
sorry John Cho yeah he was the greatest
Jon Jones grab these [ __ ] [ __ ]
kids that were about to spray-paint just
gimme that sorry don't do P [ __ ]
white kids and you just snatched their
spray paint kit but John's out there
boarding up smashed windows he's really
trying to help you know you see that guy
that is an ESPN reporter something Chris
Palmer who was like cheering on looting
and rioting and then like like right
after he someone was like our
neighboring gated community is being
targeted now get the [ __ ] away it's like
a perfect thing on Twitter like they're
right in the back it's just look that
gets what I think I was like white
liberalism this is like so many these
people would would be freaked out call
the police if any of this thing ever
happened but if happens in an affordable
housing complex in Minneapolis then we
can you know what has been interesting
is that
these riots have not just been in the
poor neighborhood or in the black
neighborhood I mean they have been all I
think that's part of why people are so
freaked out is they've been sort of
intentionally in the wealthy parts of
town is part of what makes it so
unsettling for everyone across the board
and so you know look I my only point is
you know yes
looting bad violence bad absolutely all
of that but you can't imagine that the
military is an answer to the situation I
don't know what the answer is but when
people see the chaos and the randomness
of it all that's what's really
frightening yeah when people saw what
was happening happening in Minneapolis
as there were direct result of a bad cop
killing a man right that was handcuffed
and not a threat whatsoever but then
people say okay I get these people right
then when you see them smashing windows
in Beverly Hills you're like what the
[ __ ] does this have to do with George
Floyd like what is going on here and how
are you justifying this and they're not
but that's but that's the thing is it's
not just a bad one bad cop or even just
policing right I mean let's remember
right it wasn't just one bad cop there
three other guys gonna do it Louis
Vuitton sure but what I'm saying is
that's why this spread across the
country is because the grievances aren't
specific points are not the larger
picture that one thing marches in
protests not smashing the windows of
Target you know and they did they did a
target right down the street from here
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
anything let's do nothing it has to do
with lawlessness it has to do with
people taking advantage of the situation
and escalating also it's probably
exciting people are locked up and bored
as [ __ ] and now sudden they got
something look it is in many ways
similar to war and this is why because
when people are they have a real cause
and when war is going on there's a lot
of people that I know that have served
overseas and one of the hard kind of
scary truths is it's some of the best
times they're live yeah yeah I have
Sebastian Junger wrote a great book
about it called tribe it's a fantastic
book there really gets to the psychology
of it and you know this is a guy who was
over there for long periods of time as a
journalist when you are involved in this
and you
feel like you're fighting the good fight
and you're like [ __ ] corporate America
but you know you're [ __ ] twenty years
old you believe that [ __ ] yeah you know
my friend Bridget fantasy she's uh she's
a brilliant writer and she's really
hilarious and she she was talking about
some papers that she found that she
wrote when she was 24 and she was like
those readings like holy [ __ ] like I was
so dumb but I'm looking back back at it
now as a grown grown-ass woman come what
the [ __ ] was I doing what was I thinking
I think that's what you're dealing with
a lot of these idealistic kids they
think they're gonna tear it all down and
burn it to the ground but they don't
know where their [ __ ] their cell phone
comes from they don't know who makes
their sneakers they don't know what it
what it costs to keep the electricity on
they have no [ __ ] they have no shoe in
the game I mean but a lot of a lot of
those young people though I mean look
what is their life bed and they're
graduating from college I know very well
what the what the cost is and what the
rent is and what it looks like for them
in their life going forward and that's
exactly what where that hopelessness and
nihilism comes from and that's what's
that's what really scares me is there's
this idea I mean we're like I know it's
easy to say but it really is true we've
never seen any anything like this moment
we're living through with mass
unemployment Great Depression with
pandemic with these polarized politics
where nobody feels like any any hope of
getting anything really accomplished
through Washington you add to it the
chaos and the streets and then there's
no sign that this is all just gonna snap
back to normal it doesn't seem like it's
gonna snap back at all and this all
happened like a snap that's what's
really [ __ ] up so quick because it
seemed like okay things were getting
sort of off the rails off the rails off
the rails and then all of a sudden it's
just well from Mallory when they shut
down New York City to shut down Los
Angeles first and then it was like holy
[ __ ] we're locked down at home but we
were worried about a disease and you
know I was actually encouraged during
the early days because it seemed like
people although scared we're at least it
seemed like they're being nicer to each
other and all the [ __ ] on Twitter
seemed to have subsided because people
were dealing with a real live Penn
and they were really worried about their
own life and the lives of their loved
ones then as time dragged on as the
pandemic was going into the second month
and people were really desperate now to
work economic despair kicks in anxiety
kicks in and then people got shittier
than ever people were mean and you said
something to me in 1984 you [ __ ] I'm
sorry that was me but it ripped up to a
higher level than it was before this was
just the way the lockdown was all
handled right I'm terrible exactly it's
like there was never any benchmarks
there was never any real understanding
and you know it's funny because if you
go back we were one of the only people
to be like sympathetic to the lockdown
protesters we were like hey man like
somebody steals your job like all the or
somebody takes your job says you can't
work and all this and then not
necessarily giving you the economic
benefits that you deserve that was
something that we were very
compassionate about I mean like I'm not
saying we agreed at the time like we
didn't really know but it was like
extending that level of compassion to
people who are put in that situation I
think it's really important and that's
just something the media I mean this is
the thing we were just talking about
before it's like Coronas over right like
nobody's talking about it or maybe it's
not I don't know but like I haven't seen
anybody on cable news be like these
terrible it happened like that the the
sense of threat and this the story of
the day shift didn't change that quickly
and yeah I mean where do we go from here
I think that's the thing that no one
knows and we have this presidential
election looming in November and
politics has never felt sort of more
irrelevant and that's really because I
don't think Joe Biden's got a solution
to this and Joe Biden just [ __ ]
bailing out protesters sure if he's got
a solution he already forgot it and this
is the problem with the the way that the
coalition's have broken down between the
Democratic Party and the Republican
Party is basically the Republican Party
has this affluent portion that they
cater to and then they have white
working-class that they sort of
culturally signal to and the Democratic
Party has an affluent portion like the
the [ __ ] hat like women's March type
suburban affluent white women like
that's who they cater to along with sort
of business interests in Silicon Valley
interest and then they culturally pander
and signal to the black and brown
working-class and then the incentive is
always to keep everybody divided because
if you actually had like a multiracial
working class put together then that's
where the real power would be so it's
you know it's you have two parties
basically that don't are very much
invested in things staying as they are
look riots in the streets pandemic mass
unemployment in the stock market goes up
right like I mean that's that's where we
are that the people who already have
wealth and power and position benefit no
matter what happens right if there's a
pandemic they benefit if there's you
know mass unemployment they benefit it
cuz it just show you the horseshit of
what the stock market is though that's
the thing about they feel good I mean if
you look at that this is where I want to
try and reclaim some level of positivity
that's coming out of this thing which is
that look I mean we we are in the mint
it's only in these huge moments that you
have an opportunity to actually do
something there's a like great Lenin
quote which is like something about like
a in a week ten years can have ten years
can feel like a week and then in a week
ten years worth of change can happen I'm
butchering it somebody can look around
man don't let a good crazy phrase
there's something to be said for that
and I think that this is why I'm more
optimistic from like the right than the
left I mean the leftist made this like a
kind of explicit decision to like you
know like kill the Bernie Sanders
movement realign around the white with a
white upper-middle class suburbanite
like Joe Biden is doing joga events like
literally yoga events for women okay
like he's not doing it I'll give them
$1,000 right right like you still have
people who are like people like Halle
who are like pro xenix Trump is kind of
the populist president and
I mean look I have my I have a podcast
called the realignment with my friend
Marshall Kozlov like this is literally
what we try and do and like we're
working on a few more interesting things
here but like what we try and do on the
podcast is work through what are the
actual policy positions that like a
populist right would look like like a
new trading relationship with China
everyone's like oh decoupling like we
got to stop doing trade with China what
does that may actually mean or like on
immigration like what does it actually
mean to like restrict immigration in
America like what levels like how does
it does it even in fact wages like I
would say yes and that's something that
a lot of people have tried very hard to
prove otherwise but it's about working
and with it's about you can realign the
Republican Party to not just have the
white working class but you can have
significant portions of the black and
brown people of color all working class
Americans that is a huge winning
coalition for the right in order to move
forward it only requires them to I
wouldn't say move left on on economics
but to move back to where you know to
the Center on economics away from this
more libertarian minded right and
they're not using racist rhetoric do it
is because it's always they're always
gonna call you a racist they can't say
they can't move right or can they can't
move right on cultural issues because to
them they're like shibboleths right like
you have to have the cultural issues
that's what stops it what was the term
you ship it's like a biblical term like
it's like I saw in a West Wing episode I
was more depressed I guess during the
phase of the pandemic when it just
seemed like everyone was crushed
and everyone was apathetic and everybody
was just like in their basement or in
their apartment wondering how they're
gonna make rent next month or they were
one of those frontline workers who was
you know out on the front lines making
725 to risk their life it's that you
know at CVS or whatever it was the the
fact that people are in the streets
especially of course the the people who
are peaceful and who are enraged and who
are actually taking matters into their
own hands in that way like I actually
find that too
the most hopeful thing like imagine if
if someone's life could be casually
snuffed out like George Floyd's was and
there wasn't a reaction and there wasn't
rage like to me that would be a
profoundly more troubling state of
affairs than frankly what we're seeing
right now no it's most troubling about
that footage is that he knew who's being
filmed No and then the bystanders are
there saying what are you doing like
does he have a pulse and it's so guy's
hands in his pocket it's just so casual
and he's well I don't think he I think
he has him like this yeah he had black
gloves on look like his hand was in his
pocket it's hard to tell but the point
is he was nonchalant about having his
knee on this guy's neck also he's in
like a drain so there's a divot there so
there's like an edge that's pressed
against his neck so he's got on one side
he's got a knee on his neck on the other
side he's got this cement drain the
whole thing is horrific I mean the fact
of those three cops just sat there and
let him do that and didn't I don't
understand I mean I don't know been
charged
that doesn't sound regis it also means
that they probably do that [ __ ] all the
time it wasn't unusual thing we actually
looked at the data and the reality is
they do do that [ __ ] all the time and
three fifths of the time that they use
that particular hold to unconsciousness
three fifths of the time is with
african-american men they use that when
they neon your neck to unconscious I
think it's chokehold as chokehold to
unconsciousness over five years 245
times to unconsciousness and
three-fifths of them were
african-american men so yeah it's the
cash the the video itself and how casual
it was and how standard it was the guy
passed a forged $20 bill like that's
it's insane and so if people didn't this
is a covert right and and if people
didn't feel something from that moment
and weren't in the streets right that is
what to me would be more troubling well
it's one of the worst videos we've ever
seen because it's like this Perl law
first of all it's completely unjustified
right it's not like this guy is in a
fight for his life against this guy no
no and there was no evidence at all that
he was doing anything to merit any
brutality
there was nothing I mean even he's
talking he's like as they're leading him
across the street he's not resisting
he's not trying to run away I don't know
how it got to the point where that guy
was on his neck but the fact that those
other cops is sat there
it's like [ __ ] what is happening and
and you know this is probably gonna tank
ami cocoa chars chance which is kind of
crazy because why didn't it just vetted
her for VP and then all the sudden out
of nowhere this happens it turns out in
2006 that [ __ ] cop was doing that
[ __ ] way back then and she didn't do
anything about it he had many many
civilian complaints against I can't
raise like 17 or 19 different civilian
complaints against them and nothing ever
happened there's so many good cops out
there there's so many good cops and when
you see one like that it's just there's
a great video and I've talked about this
before but I'll say it again of a Flint
sheriff from Flint Michigan talking to
these people and saying look I'm gonna
put the baton down we're gonna we're
gonna march with you but see that is the
answer to military because that that and
what did that lead to that de-escalated
that led to less right while there's
looting he's he's money of that approach
rather than crack down tear gas rubber
bullets you know and this contentious us
versus them and the you know the
militarization all of that that approach
led to less violence I agree with you
but all that approach that the crackdown
teargas
happened after the looting that's the
that's the impetus for it it's not like
they saw these people protesting they're
just gonna start shooting - your gas
into the person we saw here the first
people we saw were burning down things
in Minneapolis and they allowed that and
as Tiger was talking about that's that's
really where it all took place seeing
people get away with [ __ ] like that yeah
it's like okay now there's a fire of the
mind yeah and that fire needs to be you
know let people understand this in a war
context right like fires it like that's
why we have very like strong rules of
engaging on this can happen and that
that Minneapolis looting that target it
was a beacon it was a message any of
these [ __ ] that you're talking
about better
we can get away with this and then night
after night after night after night
that's how 5th Ave I mean you saw I'm
sure the same videos I did you would
like organized ganks like people with
car getaway cars lookouts posted on the
corner all that where where's the NYPD
right I mean that that is the with that
breakdown is a very precious thing and
this is you know on the riots front I
mean look Baltimore 2015 they had these
level of riots what happened massive
economic destruction but worse than that
is that police and many of the others
have took a much more risk-averse
approach to the way that they were going
in that community the community is
screaming for police but specifically
for this reason which is that in the
aftermath we know from many of these
rise from the MLK times and after
Baltimore it caused massive economic
destruction to these cities it is not a
noble thing to allow this to continue
it's actually your job as a city I mean
there's a whole movement I mean
underground nobody wants to say this a
lot of people do want to live in cities
now because of what happened we you know
first we're all locked
I live in an 800 square foot apartment
you don't [ __ ] terribly lock down an
800 square foot apartment and like the
only thing you do is like go to the
grocery store you can't go out to eat or
do anything and now I've got [ __ ] like
being blown up in the streets like a
couple blocks from my house like I don't
really know if that's the city life is
all that enticing it out there crystal
[Laughter]
thinking that which is that hey you
don't [ __ ] this why am I paying all this
rent to live as a soul this box and then
maybe get you know you have my [ __ ] get
working remotely you know there's
there's a good good argument for that
now to so many people realized I mean
maybe there's one good thing that's
gonna come out of this is that people
won't be stuck in cubicles and maybe
they can work from home more often I'm
concerned for the future but I I think
that there needs to be some national
address that is about law enforcement
and about the rules of engagement and
about the way we treat people that are
artists there are citizens that's our
community especially with non violent
crimes like a [ __ ] fortune right and
that's where it come on I mean those
individual cops should be held
accountable 100% and you know the fact
that the
three that just stood by like nothing
has happened Oh son they haven't been
fired no they were fired there yeah but
I mean to me that is just unconscionable
but it's it also speaks to the fact that
it was casual the fact that was repeated
the fact that there were these
complaints and nothing was ever done it
speaks to a larger systemic problem that
the data backs up and so part of you
know the challenge of this moment is
also the fact that we are essentially
leaderless like there is no trusted
national there's no trust in our
institutions
there's no trust in the media there's no
trust invested in any sort of a national
unifying figure and so it's it's another
reason why this moment is so incredibly
fraught because who would even give that
address that anyone would really listen
to yeah it's gonna help us through this
yeah he's talking through things my dad
was like he swears a lot I mean there's
there's got to be some sort of gigantic
change the way and you're talking about
there has been some change in Baltimore
because of the riots that happened there
and there's been a response and there
has to be some sort of national response
and you know one good one thing to come
out of it is there needs to be a better
system for vetting people for law
enforcement it can't just be you want
the job okay can you do 10 chin-ups do
you have a criminal record if you ever
sold heroin no okay you're a cop it
can't be that it's gotta be very
difficult to be a cop because it's one
of the most difficult jobs it's an
insanely difficult job it's crazy that
some of the most difficult jobs that we
have are the least paying they pay the
least like like teacher right like they
pay the people who literally that we
were all deemed essential now during the
pen
like who literally allow the country to
function yes make the least of anyone
enter treated like they aren't human I
mean that's the other thing like they're
fungible goods to be fired and disposed
with and thrown onto the front lines and
a pandemic and not given any protection
like that is the way that they are
treated day to day know about the
moorlands right said oh we're gonna
replace you with slaves that's actually
one thing we have implied I have enough
which is hazard pay
that means that is something that I
cannot believe it hasn't gotten done I
mean actually Mitt Romney proposed $12
extra per hour to any you know patriot
pay Mitt Romney's in a cult but he's a
very reasonable guy well and think about
like the these workers in the pork
processing today's massive outbreaks and
you know what's crazy a lot of those
people are asymptomatic it's really it's
really weird yeah yeah you know also in
prisons you know there's a lot of prison
outbreaks and they've found out that
they're asymptomatic and contrary to the
way and actually I talked about this
with Kyle kolinsky he was saying well he
look at it this way like those are the
people that have the strong immune
systems because they're constantly on
top of each other and it's true hey but
it is I mean it's also that's also how
it spread through them I mean these
people I think high stress terrible diet
you locked in a cage boy how the [ __ ]
are these people asymptomatic but this
is a weird disease and that's that's
also part of the problem is that this is
a novel coronavirus that's right that's
me about it it's just like I don't know
what the [ __ ] to believe about it right
right like there's all this thing for me
oh this study's been debunked actually
no and about everybody's got antibodies
no nobody has antibodies what antibody
test does the mortality rate is 1% point
I want like I don't know what to trust I
mean I think one of the things you
brought up which actually I thought was
great point is that why is nobody
talking about immunity here like how to
boost your immune systems wear a mask
away from everybody but not vitamin D
you know when they're dealing with these
people in New Orleans and there was a
study in Indonesia the giant percentage
like more than 80% of the people that
are in the ICU have a vitamin D
deficiency yeah for
didn't write four percent of the people
life in ICU had sufficient levels of
vitamin D and how many people in general
have a vitamin D depressive yes 70% in
counted just in this in this country not
non-california I don't know why I said
that I'm just trying to talk people in
this country have insufficient vitamin D
and 29% are deficient meaning they're in
dangerously low levels now when you add
Cova to something like that I think that
speaks to one of the problems we're
dealing with this mortality rate obesity
people with insulin resistance people
with like real underlying health
problems and you could say you know that
well you know we still have to protect
those folks and that this is the reason
why we lock down the country okay maybe
but you didn't do anything about
immunity you didn't tell anybody to do
things differently there's no public
service announcement telling people hey
if you cut down on sugar and cut down on
alcohol and take cigarettes out of your
life you have a radically increased
chance of beating this [ __ ] thing so
how are we supposed to survive in
quarantine crazy liquor stores were
deemed essential businesses and
Alcoholics Anonymous was not they shut
down Alcoholics Anonymous but they kept
liquor stores open I mean I know how
many people fell off the wagon during
this time a lot I'm sure you're anxious
but I saw some study about the the
number of Americans who are showing
signs of like anxiety and depression
during those I mean yeah it's completely
you've been cut off from all of your
coping mechanisms basically and if
you've lost your job you've lost you
know a central point of meaning in your
life and ability to provide for yourself
and your family it's it's unreal and you
know the fact that basically I remember
early on who was it was it a Steny Hoyer
in the house who was like we'll come
back and work some more if there's an
emergence of national emergency I'll
come back girl there's a pandemic and
millions of people lost their jobs what
are you tired but that's been the blasé
attitude because their career does not
repay their money
gavin newsom mark our governor one of
the [ __ ] more ridiculous quotes he said
if we keep our masks on we can get back
some of our freedoms you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] with you in LA -
because first they were like three
months yeah and then they just like took
away and I'm like wait why did they
learn something my friend Janet who owns
this fantastic restaurant in Venice they
just Felix they just told her out of
nowhere you can reopen but no
preparation all of a sudden with no
warning they said uh we're just going to
open I think cuz they're dealing with
this unprecedented economic despair
we're there and someone's like hey you
know you've only had 2,000 deaths in the
whole state there's 40 million [ __ ]
people how many people have died of
heart attacks during that time more how
many people died of cancer more how many
people died of obesity and all the
interrelated helped did problems that
come with that a lot more there's a lot
of [ __ ] people dying right 2000 is a
good number it sucks that those 2,000
people died of this disease but you
can't just shut down the whole country
you can't shut down the economy because
there is a direct correlation between a
dip in the economy and an increase in
deaths due to suicide due to drug
overdoses due to all sorts of problems
even starvation that we've been living
like that now for ten years I mean you
know since 2008 basically like we had
wipeouts of home ownership back home or
should have wealth black wealth and
black homeownership under President
Obama's presidency and it was during
that time that you know when the economy
was coming back it was a all
underemployment it was all like in the
gig economy it was all like in a way
that just it was all not in a some more
secure way that it was before the crisis
and that is actually part of why this
makes this economic crisis so bad right
because it even gets rid of those types
of jobs because going into the Great
Recession we lost a majority
middle-income jobs and coming out we
gain majority lower income jobs and
that's when the gig economy crops up and
so people are pushed even more to the
edge than they were before and you know
may not have health insurer
don't have savings like or piecing it
together with a couple different gig
jobs and there's an author who calls it
the precariat that group of workers who
you know they're piecing it together
they don't have any sort of net below
them and then you layer on top of that
like that's a group of people who is
either out on the front lines in the you
know the processing plant or delivering
the packages or doing the uber eats for
lucky folks like us you can just order
in no problem don't worry about it or
they lost their job altogether and are
just like no certainty that it's ever
going to come back how am I gonna how am
I gonna make rent this month like the
lot of rent forbearance is ending right
now and nothing has been done to help
and it's all gonna be in full total
chaos after this rioting and no one
knows what to happen I want to ask both
of you guys this okay if you had a magic
wand view the king of the world how do
we come out of this how to start with
you what do you mean how do we all of it
how do we come in this is what
everybody's wondering right the big
question everybody has right now is how
does this end how do we come out of the
economic despair caused by the pandemic
how do we come out of the riots how do
we come out of all of this I mean I
think you have to do a ubi
and you have to do some sort of mass
Federal jobs program to get people back
to get them back working to get them
back on their feet to to rebalance the
playing field I think you have to do
those two things and I would also say
universal health care how many of those
$1,200 checks went out did the only one
that's [ __ ] preposterous yeah one
time that was it and I'm like okay but
what am I supposed to keep doing that
yeah so so how do we get out of this
whole riot thing I mean I think these
things go together I also think that you
have to have some that some sort of
systemic policing reform like what
you're talking about in terms of the
training in terms of chokeholds being
illegal in order to for people to feel
like there's some real problem I don't
think you should make chokeholds illegal
I think if you're trying if someone's
trying to kill someone someone's trying
to stop someone look if
if you're a cop and you're in a fight
for your life against someone who's done
something horrible you should be able to
use jiu-jitsu and one of the best
techniques in jiu-jitsu is choking
people unconscious and it's not that
dangerous it's not as dangerous as
beating someone it's not as dangerous as
head trauma what that guy did was just
torture yeah that's what he did it has
nothing to do with utilizing a good
martial art technique to subdue some
sort of perpetrator well then here's the
other piece that is a whole other can of
worms but you know a lot of this police
think has to do with the drug war I mean
a lot of the militarization and the the
racism within policing comes back to the
the drug war in the way that we handle
all of that for sure yeah I mean but you
know it has to do with PTSD as well I
mean I think there's a ton of cops out
there running around with just
unmanageable PTSD where are you serving
the military yes a lot of citizens out
there who have PTSD for sure but they're
not pulling people over I think the
pulling people over every day with PTSD
leads to terrible choices I think
there's a lot of these cops that have
seen too much violence they've seen too
much death I was actually talking to a
friend of mine about it yesterday and
someone who she grew up with who had a
different friend he grew up with had a
friend who lives in a small town in
9,000 people and thought that where they
lived was you know it was fine normal
place and became a cop and over the
course of 10 years of being a cop it has
a completely jaded and fucked-up
attitude about human beings now because
they've walked in on people with their
brains blown out and stabbed to death
and raped and just every [ __ ] day
they find some new reason to hate
everyone and they're just broken and and
I think this is a thing that cops and
every time they pull somebody over this
could be the last day of their life this
guy's got a tinted window you know and
who knows what's going on inside this
car who knows if this is a fugitive who
knows well and that's it that's a deeper
question about our society it's not like
that everywhere I mean it's not first of
all you don't have the level of violence
everywhere that we have here you don't
have the level of cop to citizen
animosity and violence that we have here
I mean that's it that's a really deeper
question about
what we're doing in society to lead to
those outcomes I don't have all the
answers oh you're right yeah it is it's
a it's it's a an effect that has
accumulated over time - and to bring it
back in the other direction and to have
some sort of a positive relationship
between the police officers and and the
communities that they serve one thing
that my friend a mortal technique
brought up about that sheriff in Flint
he said Flint has a very unique
relationship with with the police and
the people in the community because
they're all dealing with that water
problem they're all in it together and
it's been a lot of the people that are
police officers they're also live in the
community with a and their kids were
poisoned - yes right I think people
living in the community the police is
also in the day like a lot of the cops I
didn't actually live in LA so it was
very much like a train yeah yeah they're
all in Simi Valley
don't go robbing a house and see there's
a problem in New York City as well
because it's so expensive you know -
that it makes it impossible for some
class people to be able to live in the
city that they are actually policing I
mean look there's a there's an ugly
history around policing in America if
you go back to a lot of the police
departments in the south were put in
place to enforce Jim Crow style laws I
mean there has been a long history of
basically there being a community that
is protected and a community that is
policed and so those are our deep
problems to solve you're not going to
solve them overnight you're not gonna
pick one piece of legislation that's
gonna fix it like that but I think if
you have that context and that
understanding and that you're not just
saying oh it's just this one bad person
or that one bad person that we have a
bigger structural issue then you can
start to move forward and people people
just need to feel like progress can be
made I mean I think that's one of the
biggest problems in this moment is
there's this sense of nothing is going
to change nothing has changed they had
body cameras they didn't have them on
you know they were being filmed and they
didn't [ __ ] care it didn't matter it
didn't make a difference and so if you
can at least give people that sense that
no the political system can work on your
behalf then you start to move in the
right direction it's an amazing that one
person in one
horrific act of one part of Minneapolis
and start this explosion that lights the
whole country on fire unbelievable
protest their protest overseas - yeah I
mean it's weird in New Zealand I saw
protests in New Zealand style bender was
in a protest same question to you how do
you fix this
so on the rile start with the riots cuz
I think my view is clear
re-establish law and order I agree you
use that opportunity to seize upon again
the 50-plus one things what do we all
learn through this pandemic it's pretty
stupid that our corporate elites and our
political elites allowed many of our
most critical jobs and industries in
order to go over to China
that's an empirically stupid thing yes
reassuring American supply chains makes
us safer in the long run both from a you
know and economic respect from national
security perspective health perspective
etc like the China thing is like a 90/10
issue and right now I want to make sure
I call this out which is that there are
elements in the white house more
corporate friendly ones who are trying
to quash a by American order that was
put forward you know within the Trump
administration that doesn't even call
from mandatory like on shoring of
medical supply chains but just like
wants to use subs you know tax rebates
and other stuff to encourage over ten
years and I think it's pretty
unconscionable at something like that
ninety ten issue after something like
this hasn't been passed I think on trade
it's the same thing this is a broader
question of so much of what we have it's
not just China I mean that's an
overwhelming thing in our trading
relationship but it's like a great
nation makes things for itself there's a
great essay I write it was like make
America autarkic again and autarky is
like making everything here I'm not
saying that's you know all the
libertarians are gonna get very upset
about me and start sending me
comparative advantage memes but like
look there is a real benefit to be able
to make things in America and that if
just because it's cheaper the the alter
of globalization the alter of cheap
prices has made us make horrific
political choices over the last four
decades and going on that and praying
towards that altar has made it so that
we are less safe less and less robust
less I mean socially you know the to to
live in a town and to have a factory
which is producing something and to feel
pride in your work and get paid a good
wage and to know that if the explicit
decision of Congress in order to let
China to join the WG or China to joining
the WTO restoring permanent norming
relationship permanent normal trade
relationship with China and watching
that factory go away like this you know
why and people made that choice because
they said [ __ ] you you're better off you
have it cheaper TV they said not better
GDP will go up GDP control and it did
and it was great for a few people I
think that you have to acknowledge that
there's like a deeper rot in the society
where the fundamental promise has been
like if you have cheaper stuff and you
can buy more like cheap Chinese crap
you're gonna be happy right that's gonna
be the key to happiness and so
everything has been used to justify
those ends and it hasn't made us happy
it hasn't made us satisfied it hasn't
brought us any sort of spiritual
nourishment or community and community
is something that we have completely
sort of dismissed with and dispatched
with and devalued in the country as well
so some of this is not like easy here's
a law you can pass and you're good to go
but I think it does start with this
fundamental idea which comes back to
kind of the core of our show that human
beings are worthy that they have dignity
that they have rights that should be
secured and if you can take that kind of
FDR economic rights model and actually
implement it into place where people
feel that they are valued and seen and
heard and have agency and power in the
society then you are not going to have
to call in the military to American
cities you're not going to end up with a
situation like we see right now that's
spiraling and spiraling and spiraling
out of control that's another thing you
know in terms of what I would do it's
like we have to we have to reorient our
economic life and our economic policies
in order to incentivize the building of
communities and the building of
institutions that exist outside of just
the outside of just a direct check from
the government or direct check from your
work force it's each needs to be about I
mean the way that America was like the
probably most United we ever war
was around like in the 1960 I know
everyone there were terrible things that
happened they were exposed in the Civil
Rights there and all that but you know
broadly what was it was like unions it
was about higher wages and it was about
the strength of the American family and
that's something that I mean every data
we see Lois marriage rate on record in
2018 because and what's the number one
reason that people cited not being able
to get married I think it's not know man
people still want to get married it's
just that they can't afford to marriage
is not sure think we need to reorient
our economic life in order to bolster
the American family and this this this
is something very much part of like the
new right movement there's this new
organization called American Compass run
by a friend of mine Oren cast he used to
work for Mitt Romney and now what he's
trying to do is you know move the GOP on
these issues towards centering economic
like restoring like economic
conservatism from economic
libertarianism and what I mean by that
is free market fundamentalists at the
free market is always good look like the
free market was it is it a good thing
once again that we couldn't make
ventilators in our country when we
thought we needed them like was it a
good thing that we couldn't manufacture
our own medical supplies and then
broadly like in terms of the immediacy
what I would do it's this payroll plan
it's so critical that we restore
Americans payroll and that we try to
make it so that these businesses don't
become failed distressed assets that get
rolled up into these huge private equity
conglomerates that buy them all off for
cheap that [ __ ] over workers it [ __ ]
businesses and it just makes this do you
want to live in a highly in a world
where there's no mom-and-pop businesses
or no dive bars anymore that's where
we're headed right I think two people
will put up with a lot of [ __ ] and they
will persist and they will invest in a
communal invest in their lives they'll
invest in a productive civil society if
they feel that they have they they
believe that life will get better for
themselves and their kids and I really
think that's kind of the core breakdown
that people no longer have that
confidence that for their kids it's
gonna they're gonna be able to have it
better than they had and when you lose
that sense of hope that's when things go
off the rails I think there's also a
real problem with this election in that
you either are a pro Trump person in
which you're happy that Trump's gonna
run again but if you're a Democrat
you're really settling we all know
you're really really settling you're
making me right now Joe everyone who's
on the left has any sense attention well
and also that you it so clearly
highlights the people that are full [ __ ]
that are just supporting the fact that
you know you want you're gonna vote left
no matter what and you hear this thing
look I'm just voting for the cabinet I'm
voting for the one thing that I keep
hearing over and over again is I'm
voting for a woman's right to choose and
I'm like okay do I agree with the
woman's right to choose but is that the
number one thing for running the country
is a person's ability to abort a baby is
that really what cuz that really is what
it boils down to and I'm not you know
I'm not saying that lightly
but what it's it's very sad that we're
in this position in 2020 that we we have
to say I'm just voting for the cabinet I
just want to vote left
I'm voting for the Supreme Court we cut
we covered this member there was a and
this was Democrats made fun of Trump
voters for being koltes last time around
Trump came out and said I can shoot
someone in Fifth Avenue they'd still
vote for me and we're like you're an
idiot right that's ridiculous a woman if
an Asian writer at the nation just wrote
this piece piece that she started off if
Joe Biden boiled and ate babies I would
still vote for him now look is she being
hyperbolic of course but the central
concept of like it doesn't matter what
he does it doesn't matter I will justify
it if it's just a hair's breadth better
in my view than Trump and look I mean
ultimately maybe the election is that
existential and maybe things are going
off through that you're just like okay
well at least Joe is gonna be you know
somewhat normal and do sort of normal
presidential things
but that type of politics is deeply
destructive because if everything can be
justified if you're just like slightly
better than the other side this lesser
two evils dynamic is a hell that you
could never escape from isn't he he's 78
yeah
so he'll be 86 wait a sec is he's 78 or
so nice I think he's 77
yeah much more vibrant feels like he's
falling apart and the idea that he's
gonna be here in eight years cuz this is
a problem you're voting for him not just
for now you're voting for him if he wins
you're hoping you last two terms you're
also you're also voting for whoever its
vice president is who not only maybe you
know will be the next Democratic nominee
and then you know eight years of them
but also because of his decline may have
a lot more influence and power may be
pulling the strings depending on who it
is and look he's already said he wants
to pick someone he's consulting with
Wall Street as to who we should pick his
donor class is like having a lot of say
over who he should pay he's gonna pick
someone who's basically just like him
ideologically so you're looking at maybe
twelve years of essentially being like
well I guess this is guess I'm voting
for the cabinet vice president is gonna
be like a democratic it's gonna be some
sort of a dick cheney situation we have
heard my favorite quote from Biden is he
wants to make the Democratic Party a
bridge to Peter James like people like
Pete and that was like whoa I'm so
comfortable that's the bridge I was
ready to ride in the streets I don't
know if he's a nice guy but he just
seems so plastic it seems so real yes
it's empty it's just about he's a young
guy
- which is part of the problem you're
thrusting someone into the national
spotlight that was just a mayor and
running while he was a mayor that
doesn't I don't understand that
one year our mayor isn't it really
[ __ ] important to take care of your
city well and his wasn't doing
were one of the only peoples in the
people in the primary who even covered
how the city of South Bend itself felt
about P ang there's there's this like
celebrity culture around politicians now
it's kind of like we were talking about
earlier like Cuomo's oh it does a great
press conference and that's all that
matters
there's this Stacey Abrams who's also
been talking about for a vice
presidential pick there she sort of
created this brand image of being very
much on the left very progressive a very
different sort of politician but if you
actually look at her record in Georgia
she was you know and this is not like
maybe if you're a centrist this is a
good thing it's not my politics but she
was very centrist corporate friendly
that was the type of politician that she
was and no one ever actually covers her
record which is kind of fundamentally
disrespectful to her she's a politician
she did things she has a record instead
it's this like Kardashian type coverage
she checks all the diversity boxes
that's exactly yeah I was talking about
the mayor of Chicago when I was there I
was like she's woman she's black and
she's gay if she just was a transgender
and a Muslim she would have all the
Infinity stones and she'd be the wolken
that ever existed where dreadlocks would
glow and seen a video where she's
talking about we interviewed her there's
a video where she's talking about the
New World Order there's this video
that's being passed around and
conspiracy theory to order yeah
Jamie Jamie could find the video I think
Eddie Bravo put it on his Twitter page
it says a lot or his Instagram page but
is essentially she was talking about
picking leaders that will comply with
the the New World Order I don't know
what the context of what she was saying
but then it got passed around like look
she's a New World Order she'll
I don't know 5g cover your head
[ __ ] 5g man it's it's everywhere be
careful right yeah she's she's a you
know a very popular politician for a lot
of good reasons but it's also one of
those things where when someone says
something like New World Order you say
just that phrase alone like that's a
hot-button phrase for all the conspiracy
people right well and when you have this
when you have no one who's trusted in
the media and when you have this sort of
general societal breakdown in general
then that stuff flourishes more than it
would in normal times these echo
chambers of conspiracy theorists and
left-wing people who are pundits and
right-wing people these echo chambers
are some of the most disturbing parts of
interaction with people online because
you can always find someone that agrees
with you and you know if you're not a
person that likes to challenge your
thoughts and ideas you can just bounce
those [ __ ] things around with all
these other knuckleheads to believe the
same [ __ ] you do that's definite no it's
in fact check to be out of context of
course I just want to know what the hell
she's saying otherwise it doesn't work
so you can eliminate that compliance and
you make a mandate and then you do
training particularly in the city I'll
call the licensing departments whether
it's zoning buildings housing will be
impacted by a planning certainly and
it's and you and you pick the people who
run those agencies and the deputies
there are pledging allegiance to the New
World Order and good governance and then
I think you have inspector general I
can't I get what she was trying to say I
think which is like a new era of city
government is that is that with no she's
saying lord Vader so Saeng pledge
allegiance the lord Vader open your eyes
is mandatory show everyone get your 5g
see he's covering for them to remember
what Bill Gates is the devil get your
microchips [ __ ] you Bill Gates is a bad
guy now how did that happen
did you see Trump stand in front of the
church holding that Bible like as a
dirty diaper that was great is hilarious
first of all they teargas all the
[ __ ] protesters to get him off the
street the clearance tree down and then
Trump walks across the street like
there's never been a president so bold
to walk he's walking so he walks across
the street says boarded down Church it's
hilarious I mean they probably had
snipers all over the room a Dilla yeah
it's a dirty diaper he's holding that
thing like like look I've got my Bible
[ __ ] read me one passage asked
if it was his Bible he's like thank you
sir I got it at a hotel I was Dan yeah I
mean what what is that why is he holding
the Bible what that is the most
ill-conceived PR stunt that I've ever
seen
I mean maybe yeah I actually thought
about this too because look I mean their
main reason the main reason like Trump
has such a solid hold on the on the
right like on the Republican base so to
speak is because actually of the judges
thing of the Supreme Court thing which
you were talking about of selecting Mike
Pence who has a lot of credibility in
the evangelical community so I think
that I mean a lot of people were
outraged I saw this this was a very like
right thing when that you know the st.
John's Church that church that you were
seeing that was set on fire right and so
like it was set on fire and there was a
lot of people like first of all there I
think it was brian Stelter over at CNN
was like actually no it's not on fire
they delete his tweets and on Twitter
who's betcha is adorable he's adorable
little shell he's something else but so
like there was all that and there look
there wasn't a lot of outrage around the
fact that the church got set on fire so
I get what he was signaling it look I
agree I told Krystal this morning on the
show tear gassing the protesters and
going out there for the Photoshop on
like that I don't think it was the best
move can you imagine being so insecure
that you're the president
of the United States like you have
nuclear arsenal and middle American
military at your disposal and you're so
insecure that you have to show your
strength in that moment by walking
across the park and reportedly he was
upset because it had come out that they
had like had to go down into the bunker
on Friday or say at a Saturday night or
whatever when there were protesters and
so this was his way to reassert his
manhood but I think that's why I say I
don't think that he has like a real I
think he has instincts I don't think he
has a real ideology I don't think he has
like a goal or a mission or a project
he's trying to accomplish I think he's
just all it I think it's all just about
like how do I reclaim this news cycle
how do I win the day I actually
interviewed him back before he was an
official candidate at the White House
Correspondents Dinner I was doing like I
was like on the rope line doing like the
celebrity interviews like sticking a mic
in people's face right over it was
ridiculous so he comes in and this is at
the time and Aaron's like oh it's just a
publicity stunt he's not gonna run right
he comes in with Milani it wasn't the
one it was maybe the one after when
Barack Obama made fun of him like that
and so he comes up to me and this is
when I was at MSNBC and you know I
wasn't like particularly prominent there
it was one of four on a panel show and
he locks eyes with me and he's like
crystal oh my god it is so great to meet
you
like even then this he was like re and a
b torik
you guys are so great together on the
cycle like he knew the show he knew
clearly he was had already obsessed with
cable news and all the ins and outs of
cable news and he was general oh my god
I can't believe I get to meet Krystal
I'm like what no but it was such a
little insight into his whole wiring and
so he knows more than anyone like what
is going to be provocative to these
stupid Talking Heads on cable what is
gonna capture their attention what is
gonna be outrageous what's gonna win the
day and I don't think that there's much
beyond that thinking of like how do I
win this news cycle how do I change the
topic on this news cycle so there's
certainly part of that but the thing is
that wouldn't explain why Trump has been
skeptical of the global
financial system since like 1978 right
like there's that old clip of him on
Oprah in like 1980 about Japan and Jade
I mean he's he's even I've heard this
from a friend he was sighting like one
of my friends michael lind who's like
very you know like a nationalist on
trade policy in the mid-2000s was like
michael lind is right about trade like
he was he's clearly been thinking about
this for a long time and on immigration
in particular I mean I think that's
another one where he's always kind of
been there he's always had the instant I
mean his real genius was looking at what
did the base of the Republican Party
actually want they want better trade
deals and they want less immigration and
for you know decades now all the
professional right has been able to give
them is will cut your taxes that's a
priority it'll never actually happen and
then that is that and then alt but you
still have to vote for us because we're
good on abortion and we're good on gun
control and that wasn't enough for a lot
of people and you can see - and this is
what I meant about making it the cynical
choice when you adjust your position on
immigration and on trade you win all of
these Obama Trump voters all throughout
the Midwest and you become the president
I mean and even then I'm not saying it
was enough there still is a lot of more
work to be done I think it needs to
realign more to the issues of what I'm
talking about but to say that it's all
just it is just I mean that's not his
his driving force like if you see the
way I'm having interacted with him and
just like how he how he reacts to
certain things there isn't condensed
ideology behind what he is otherwise he
wouldn't have run the way was he
wouldn't have had those positions for
such a long time on the core issues that
actually matter to why he was elected
and so the real issue and I think the
criticism of valid criticism is he
wasn't able to enact those political
instincts into the actual staffing of
the White House because in the White
House personnel most policy and there's
a great there's a great book called the
years of Lyndon Johnson then it's about
history of LBJ has four volumes and all
that Robert acara one of the best
biographers of all time and he quotes a
guy named Tommy Corcoran who was FDR's
kind of right-hand man he's like what is
a government government's not one-man
government is the first hundred men
first thousand they all have to be
united in the common purpose in order to
actually get [ __ ] done in a bureaucracy
the truth is and we have to acknowledge
this is that on the right after Trump's
election the RNC and all these
professional right-wingers these
conservative establishment they were the
thousand and so that's why you get
something like the tax cuts bill the tax
cuts in Jobs Act it's because a guy like
you know Paul Ryan has been fantasizing
about pushing that for such a long time
he didn't agree with Trump on trade he
blatantly disagree he didn't agree with
Trump on immigration completely and they
were these guys were masters about Oh
mr. Presiden you gonna get that but you
got to pass this tax cut first right
oh you you'll get what you want and
you're spending but he just got to put
this in the spending bill first and they
snookered basically they snookered him
because Trump isn't I mean look he was a
political novice he didn't actually know
about how policy was made in Washington
DC it's [ __ ] complicated it matters a
lot who the Deputy Secretary of Commerce
is like you and I aren't gonna know that
person's name that person certified
certifies like steel tariffs yeah I
still think that's letting him off the
hook too much though because like I mean
you see in this in this crisis right if
he may he may have some instincts he may
have some ideological leanings and
you're right he's been talking about
this some of this stuff especially on
trade for a long time but when it came
down to it you know he was the first
people he called in the coronavirus
crisis for economic response were
corporate ceos Wall Street executives
like that's who we went to to get his
advice that's who I trusted and that's
how you end up you know floating ideas
like we're gonna have a capital gains
tax cut as a response to the crisis or
we're gonna have a payroll tax cut which
okay if you have a range of responses
maybe that's part of it but when you've
got 40 million people who aren't on a
payroll anymore
that's not gonna do a whole heck of a
lot of good so I just don't see that
there's any maybe he has the ideology
but doesn't really matter if you're not
willing to push for a for now and you
see who's organized in the town because
immediately once this crisis hit
immediately the first Trilly multi
trillion dollar bill gets passed very
very quickly with all the goodies for
big business this stuff that was custom
written every got their goodies there
was a massive tax break for real estate
developers that they tried to get into
the corporate bailout that they had all
ready to go like those are the forces
that are all completely organized locked
and loaded
ready to go in a crisis and so they
basically won I mean they rolled
everyone they tied the little bit of
poultry small business and worker stuff
to the massive corporate piece and held
the workers and the small businesses
hostage and so if you vote don't vote
for it then you're voting against
workers and it was all ready to go like
that and that is what you were
overcoming in the town that sort of
bipartisan 98 Oh 9800 I think when
you're talking about Trump in his
history of understanding trade and in
business decisions I think it's all
stuff that benefited him that's why he
was concentrating on them and I think
now you're dealing with him spread so
thin because now he has to deal with the
environment he has to deal with
international politics and there's so
much and that's why you you catch him
and I think what you said too that he's
lives off the it'd I mean I think that's
very true and he's always in the moment
right he famously said he just lives off
of his instincts he trusts his instincts
yeah which is great but he had
preparation when he was dealing with
those things before when he's talked
about those things before he was
president that's why I had a deeper
understanding of them because they meant
something to him yeah but now you're
dealing with the entire broad spectrum
of duties of being the president and he
says [ __ ] like inject people with Lysol
and sick dogs on protesters he's saying
nutty things she's the strong man right
he's always been the strong man he's
always been the you're fired guy right
and he's still planet yes height yes
so he's that guy now but he's that guy
with global thermonuclear consequences
and so that even more to the point on
that which is that when you don't have
this is this is another kind of
establishment always wins point is that
when you don't have very firm beliefs
because like trade and immigration are
two things with like hundreds of
billions of dollars behind the kernel
liberal trade and immigration policy
that we have right now in this country
when you don't have that a very well
formed ideology around how it should be
like you're saying on the environment or
anything else that is how they win
because status quo always continues in
DC unless you make the very concerted
effort of like no you are not doing
anymore and I'm appointing your boss and
your boss's boss and your boss's boss's
boss's boss in order to make sure that
you don't actually do that that's that's
actually what the hardest way to fight
back is you actually need a coherent
ideology on every single one of these
things but more important you got to
understand how government works and I
think that so many people don't seem to
grasp that it's not just like putting a
guy in the Oval Office like look by the
time it's reached the Oval Office it's
so [ __ ] right that ten levels down
they would have made the decision so
that's the power right like you got to
make sure that you're what you want is
being reflected ten layers down in the
bureaucracy and you look at the way you
know like Russia gate and all this other
stuff and you can just see like how
arrogant some of the people within the
bureaucracy behave just blatantly you
know disregarding the will of a
president or blatantly just thinking
he's illegitimate trying to deal legit
amazing and from that perspective that's
[ __ ] scary because they're not even
accountable to the person that we all
voted for that is what what I like why
why conservatives have to care more
about government that's something I like
one of my pet causes is look like we are
living in a society where the culture is
against you like we are living in a
society where you know the cultural
elite the commanding heights of American
culture and you're living in a society
where you don't have real power there
and so and you're also living in a
society where you have corporate America
look at these protests right now Amazon
supports the protests right like well
Amazon supports the protests Citibank
CEO it's it's the people with the most
accumulated capital in America are also
on the side of this protest why because
in my view they use identity politics
and racial politics they want to split
the country along those lines every
single day that we're talking about
identity politics and having debates
about race well not really want to split
the country along the lines I think they
just want support for their company so
and they think that it's a good PR move
it's a it's a brand new and here's the
thing is and this goes back to the
coalition's of the parties right so the
Democratic Party caters largely to these
like white affluent women basically is
like the base that they really right I
know they chew a lot of clothes
Humiliator with this base I wanna see
Jobar
the joga base and so you know for those
four people who are more or less doing
well as things are right they've got
their health insurance they've got a job
where they're treated like a human being
with humanity they can get their Ober
eats they can get whatever they want on
demand right their way of virtue
signaling is on identity issues and if
you only confine the conversation on
policing to like let's deal with this
let's let's have more body cameras like
if you keep it in that lane that's very
comfortable for that right if you have a
broader conversation about a society
that you know has decimated unions has
decimated working-class power about who
has power in the society and why like
that's more of a threat to them so yes
for corporate brands it's very
comfortable to have like let's have a
diversity initiative it's less
comfortable to say no no let's actually
value the worth of everyone let's
actually have a different set of power
let's actually not have corporations
able to give on Lemon and limited money
and buy off our politicians and then be
able to go work on your boards etc etc
like that's a very non-threatening
conversation that's how you end up with
was a Bank of America sponsored the the
movement continues yes black lives
matter movement continues with DeRay
McKesson is a prominent activist to be
cynical is there another reason why
Amazon would support this protest that
this is kind of the death of retail I
mean this is one of the final nails in
the coffin of retail so think about
investing your money in a
brick-and-mortar store with a glass
window after all this horseshit
look III won't cite who told me this was
a very prominent person in the field of
economics and was like my conspiracy
theory is that Jeff Bezos wants 10 to 15
percent unemployment because then what's
the best job in the world Joe in a rural
place Amazon warehouse he's the guy
dropping off those bricks who's better
at delivering [ __ ] than Amazon you
should be more cynical because that I
mean look how else do we get to a point
where like the shale gas company
sponsors a 16:19 project event with
nicole hanna jones around with it so the
16:19 project
a real rabbit hole so this is like this
is the New York Times put out the sting
and 16:19 project is the year that the
first slaves were brought to America and
it was about reforming the way that we
talk about race and slavery in America
and so that the very first essay which
she wrote which is very controversial as
when she claimed that the reason for the
American Revolution was because people
wanted to keep their slaves not because
of you know control from England and all
that what happened is is that a bunch of
very prominent historians are on the
American Revolution the Civil War and
much more pan to the essay they said
this thing needs to be corrected they
corrected it even then she still won the
Pulitzer Prize for journalism or for
commentary I want to say for that
specific essay which was which was there
and they partnered I think was with the
Pulitzer Center in order to create
curriculum that schools are now using to
teach now this was attacked the 16:19
project not at first by conservatives of
course conservatives were pissed off it
was attacked by the inner world
socialist web site by Trotskyites by
Marxists and socialists and the reason
why is because they saw it for what I
see it which is that it's a cynical
attempt in order to say America is an
irredeemably racist nation that that is
the only single and most pressing
problem that we have in our society and
if you hold that frame then you don't
ask questions about corporate power in
America you don't ask questions even of
leaders a friend of our shows that
Jelani had a fantastic appearance on our
show I really encourages everybody to go
watch it where he talks about if you
look at the black community in America
which is what had the most pressing
impact on their life economically and
destroyed so much of their livelihood
it was the foreclosures under Barack
Obama and it was the wipeout of black
homeownership and black wealth that that
the 16:19 project and the framework of
politics that that original sin which of
course is the original sin is the be-all
end-all for why we are where we are
today absolves current political leaders
and recent political leaders like Barack
Obama himself or like leaders in the
city of Atlanta or leaders in the city
of Baltimore and that it absolves public
policy which is non racial and so when I
say that why does shale gas company feel
comfortable sponsoring an event in which
the
main messages that core is that America
is an irredeemably racist nation because
they that is one more event which is
being talked about in the political
zeitgeist by the cultural elite
which is not talking about their own
power in the marketplace and if you look
at who what is the the predominant
control in your life in America it is
about capital it's not about race it's
about class class but class
disproportionately affects people of
color in America and so the way I look
at it is that identity politics is so
cynically grafted on by the billionaire
and the corporate class there's a reason
they're all super woke it's because they
want it to be this way so that we don't
talk about their power in our society
and I think this was a very cynically
the way this all happened is kind of a
crazy because it started out in the
sociology departments in the 1970s all
of these crazy you know this from the
post and the 60s era they were you know
in these sociology departments and they
started cranking out all these
absolutely crazy papers around you know
feminism and play identity politics
racial politics all of that and then
what happened is is that corporate
America and other cultural eats first of
all were being indoctrinated in the
university system they were going to go
work at places like McKinsey and others
and they brought their racial politics
and their identity politics with them
but that there had to be recognition
from the top from people at like Goldman
Sachs if Goldman Sachs if the pressure
on them is to stop the way that they
trade derivatives or to put a black
person on their board while they
continue to you know do the derivatives
trading they can choose that every
single time right so they want to direct
the conversation in that direction it
absolves them for the sins both you know
towards the economically disenfranchised
in America but it's also a very cynical
tool which is that why is it that you
see all these corporations skog tweeting
out black lives on our Instagram
blackout all that stuff how is it that
you see like night you know Nike isn't
this the great irony that Nike you know
went and did the whole Colin Kaepernick
thing the ad campaign and they still got
all their [ __ ] looted in this in this
most we say
it's Chicago right I mean I think that
is that's the perfect example of they
try to cynically use identity politics
in America split people apart to protect
their power and if we start to
understand that it's a lot more about
class in America than it is about race
I'm not saying that there is not racial
problems in America racism that so you
know all of this but that if you focus
on these class issues it's the best way
to help people people who are
disenfranchised who are
disproportionately people of color but
to help everybody that's a much more I
just don't know how else we can live in
a multi-faceted multifaceted nation like
this which is you know economically
heterogeneous ethnically people you know
so many people of different ethnicities
so many people have different religions
so maybe I mean I am the son of Indian
immigrants
I feel fully and completely American
that's an amazing thing that didn't just
happen it was the product of a result of
very specific political choices that we
made over time and it's moving towards
that that we needed to go towards and
that's what but by doing so what you've
talked about many times about economic
not just distribution but about the POW
who has power in society working-class
or not yeah which is the corporate
America can use the identity politics in
order to make sure the working class
doesn't continue to have power and so
you can't separate class and race
because it's not an accident of course
that black and brown people are
disproportionately the lower-income and
poor and working-class in society I mean
I I see it much more simply sort of like
what you were saying who it's it's
virtuous it's like brand a branding
exercise right and there's this whole
idea I always think it's hilarious on
the right flag
Facebook and Twitter are progressive or
their liberal companies or Amazon's a
liberal coming I'm like what are you
talking about Amazon treats their
workers like [ __ ] they bust unions like
this is not a left company right but
because they use this or branding tools
and tweet out black lives matter which
is no threat to them and in fact as
you're pointing out may very much
benefit their bottom line ultimately
they're sort of they get all the
benefits of being for progress and
meaning for this rising coalition in
America without actually having to do
anything that's going to benefit their
bottom line yeah listen we just did
three hours just flew by what
yeah I've really enjoyed it I really
appreciate you guys I really appreciate
your perspective I really appreciate the
fact that you guys are you're putting
out your honest informed opinions and it
really helps people like me that are way
too lazy to look the [ __ ] up on their
own
awesome and I love the fact that you
disagree but you do so intelligently and
respectfully and you you you you cut
through all the nonsense that's on most
of these political shows this this is so
much nonsense and I think the world's
sick of it and I think that's one of the
reasons why you guys are gaining in
popularity means a lot to seriously I
mean we found out we're coming here is
just so great like I've been listening
to you for years I started buying elk
meat because I bought some of that for
sig Matic coffee you know thank you for
everything Joe you created the space for
people like us in our politics and for
us to thrive and we can't ever
underestimate that I think that's why
you are so popular and you've you've
really invented the medium for a new
discussion it's a revolutionary Asian
media and there's never been more
exciting it's a complete accident I have
no idea how I stumbled onto it I just
just keep doing it but you guys are very
valuable I appreciate you very much
thank you thank you tell people on
social media and yes
so subscribe at the hill and our show is
rising and then i'm on twitter at
crystal ball instagram at crystal m ball
and that's crystal with a k' by the way
and the hill you can also at a sagar esa
AGA are on twitter same on instagram
also you can go to rising sub stack calm
or just have a list of all the links
everything you need beautiful thank you
thank you Joe
bye everybody
[Music]